I'll just add,
just dropped.
I just dropped something on
the keyboard and hit right.
Oh well it's perfect timing
ladies and gentlemen.
That's the story of this fucking show
where we're never exactly right with
anything.
It's always a mess,
but at least my phone's off.
I think the Joe Rogan experience podcast
is brought to you by onnit.com uh,
if you go to o n n I t and
use the code name Rogan,
you will save 10% off
any of the supplements.
And uh,
that includes,
uh,
hemp force,
the delicious hemp protein supplement
that we actually have to get from Canada.
Ladies and gentlemen,
this is how goof we are as human beings.
Hemp is legal to own in this country.
It's legal to sell,
it's legal to buy,
but you can't grow it.
You can't grow it.
You have to grow.
And in Canada,
it's one of the dumbest fucking things
about this country that this amazing
plant is a illegal,
and it's not even psychoactive.
That's the other thing
you have to consider.
It's,
it's this,
just a textile and just
a food and just apply.
You can't get high from it.
There's very,
very little THC in hemp,
but the fact that it's illegal is one of
the dumbest things about agriculture in
this country.
It's so ridiculous because
it's a very worthwhile plant.
It's an excellent source of protein and
we combine it with raw cocoa and Maka
and it's fucking delicious.
It is seriously one of the best tasting
protein powders you can ever get because
it's sweetened with Stevia.
So it only has one gram of sugar.
So it's not poison you,
it doesn't make you feel sick and
it's really easily digestible.
It's fucking fantastic.
We also started selling recently,
we started selling a lot
of fitness equipment.
We have kettlebells,
battle ropes,
shit that makes you manly.
It's all like serious workout shit.
The uh,
the type of a full body workouts that
you see like UFC guys doing in the,
those countdown shows,
like that's a,
that's what kettlebell
workouts are all about.
That's what battle ropes are all about.
And I've been doing a lot
of battle rope Steph lately,
Brian.
Yeah.
Sounds awesome.
Um,
go neighborhoods
save 10% off supplements.
The end with that.
We met all those on guys by the way in
Austin and was the full time that we got
to meet the whole entire staff and what
an amazing group of fucking employees,
Mans
awesome humans.
It was beautiful there.
The set,
it's just like Aubrey.
It's like,
you know what?
The dude is so positive and he's so,
he's so healthy like to talk to.
He sold there and present and then he
just surrounds himself with likeminded
people.
He just,
it was weird seeing it.
The faces behind the company,
it's a company you never get to see.
The employees totally see that.
The
trickle down man,
when you have a cool dad,
you know you have cool kids.
When you have a cool boss,
you have cool employees like that.
A guy can figure that out and how to
assemble such an awesome group of people
like that.
I don't know why I use that data analogy.
I think Bobby's Daddy,
he's still daddy.
Anyway,
Jesus Christ is going to be a long day.
We're also brought to
you by kerosene games.
This is the newest sponsor.
We're very excited about this because
it's a game company that is making,
uh,
they're making games
for directly for IPADS,
the directly for,
um,
I iPads and iPhones,
so it's not like they're porting
other games over to these,
to these platforms.
They're,
they're making them for tablets and
smartphones and the visuals are fucking
fantastic.
And their first game
is called blade runner.
And you know,
it's typical shit.
You play some crazy dude who's a bionic
cowboy and you're returning home from
years at war.
It's fun shit.
And the,
the residents have turned evil
and corrupted by dark magic.
It's all really stunning visuals and the,
the people who are behind kerosene games,
this young company and they
just seem cool as fuck.
They became connected to us through
Brian's friend Ryan Ryan Kelly.
She hooked him up with it and uh,
we liked the way they think.
We like what they're trying to do.
And a,
and Brian,
you've played the game.
Yeah,
yeah,
I've actually been playing it.
It was my first time
ever doing a Beta test,
like for the IPAD,
which is weird.
You have to put it in like this code and
you download like this thing that you
can't get in the APP store.
So it was a really fucking
interesting for me,
uh,
doing that.
And so yeah,
I've been playing with it for,
I don't know,
maybe three months.
I've gone through a lot of
builds of it and shit like that.
It's,
it's a fun game.
It's really awesome to see the,
how powerful the uh,
that iPhone is.
You know,
the iPhone is really fucking powerful.
Yeah.
What I'm trying to do even as a computer.
Like the,
the,
for gaming,
it's,
it's pretty interesting.
Interesting to see how,
uh,
like the Nintendo game boy used to be
the biggest thing Nintendo is hurting
right now because of the iPad and tablets
and stuff like that because they are
now the,
the best game boy and
intend to refuses to,
to go on any of these androids and
released like their old classics and stuff
like that in the iPad because they
know once they start doing that,
they're killing themselves.
They're shooting themselves in the foot,
you know,
and their latest a Nintendo,
we has the controller
that has a tablet on it,
you know,
so it's like a tablet.
So they're trying to slowly like,
hey,
no,
we got tablet type stuff.
Yeah,
they're fucked.
But yeah,
really fun.
This game is a perfect example of why man,
this company,
like I,
I'm not sure how many
people are in this company,
but this game is awesome and,
and you can get it right now.
I think I just,
I just purchased it,
uh,
because I have been playing on
the Betas and stuff like that,
but it's on the iPad store
right now and you can,
uh,
I think it's like a 299
or something like that or
there must be a way,
I bet they'll probably invented soon to
make it so that you can link up your TVs
with your,
your iPads.
Can you do that?
Can you play like on a big screen TV,
uh,
send it?
Well,
yeah.
I mean you can actually,
the apple TV,
yes,
yes.
With Apple TV.
Does it work?
Does it look good?
Uh,
yeah,
it's awesome because these new
iPods and stuff like that or 10,
you know,
they have,
you can watch HD videos.
I think that like those consoles,
like the Xbox there.
Fuck.
Then because the input
that you get from pads,
from tablets,
this,
it's the best input,
the touching input,
the ability to control things like that.
Like every those buttons,
seam of SAR can.
Okay.
We have to the trailer right now that the
viewers are watching for this game on.
Here's kerosene games right here,
but we can't even show Kara,
do you want me to look at it real quick?
Check out.
This is an iPad came.
This is like something that
you would only see like,
like this looks like an Xbox game.
This looks like a ps three
game and this is on your iPad
on Ustream.
It looks like shit.
Wow.
Yeah,
so it's a,
it's one of those games that were like,
when somebody attacks you,
use your finger to swipe them and
to attack them and stuff like that.
I've been playing with it for a while.
It's great.
I highly recommend it,
especially for the price
when you're thinking of it
like an Xbox game that looks
like this.
X box games or $59.
This is like two 99 I believe.
So check it out on the iTunes store.
It,
I'm not sure if it's on android or not.
I think it might be actually uh,
yeah.
I don't know if it's on
the coming soon to Android,
but yeah,
in the APP store right now.
Yeah.
And it's called the blade slinger.
Late slinger.
It's only two 99 and uh,
it looks a lot cooler
than it does on Ustream.
Unfortunately.
Our Internet sucks the fat one,
so we're,
we're stuck in this terrible position
where we're grainy right now too.
Yeah,
yeah.
We're granting is fuck.
Well,
I'm trying something different
just so we could have,
this might work.
I'm a screen capturing
my computer right now,
so I might be able to have a video,
a better quality video.
Really.
Yeah.
So I'm trying to do some slick,
hacky,
stupid shit.
Hmm.
Okay.
Good luck with that shit.
Last last spots are,
I promise we're also
brought to you by ting.
This is the longest sponsor
day we've ever had folks.
You know why?
Cause I'm a whore.
That's why they are sad.
A Tang is a mobile company that
we have been doing business with,
uh,
for,
for several months now.
And we really like them.
We really liked what they're doing.
They um,
they have,
uh,
a company that uses a sprint backbone
and so you're getting like a major,
you know,
Internet,
cellular provider,
but you don't have the
same sort of contracts.
You can cancel anytime you want.
You,
um,
they,
they refund you on your next
bill if you don't use minutes.
I mean they give you,
they,
they like literally chop your,
your rate on the next
bill if you don't use,
like I say,
if you use less than you're
allotted amount of minutes,
they're like a very fair
and very ethical company.
And the,
um,
the idea behind them I
think is really cool.
It's like you can make money,
you just don't have to be
super fucking greeting.
And they have really nice
high level android phones,
including the Samsung Galaxy s
three which I have and it's awesome.
It's fucking beautiful.
Um,
I,
they're sending me when supposedly,
supposedly what the fuck it's been weeks.
I think they're sending it by mail.
I think they put it on a donkey.
Yeah.
Mexican male or something?
No.
Like I like this male is like ridiculous.
Like,
like the cheapest though.
The USBS has a,
I don't think that's possible
because someone must have fucked up.
They forgot to send it.
They traded,
they contacted me,
said that they wanted to send you
one and they even got your address.
I sent it to them.
Everything was confirmed.
Ting.
What the fuck?
I never has their new galaxy
s three go to rogan.ting.com.
Oh,
it's,
is that it?
Yes.
Okay.
It was something different
at one point in time,
go to [inaudible] dot com and you can
get a $50 credit to get started on one of
their super sweet,
big,
fat,
juicy android phones.
And again,
there's no contracts.
You can,
you can share minutes with
a friend or a loved one.
And uh,
just a,
a cool company doing business
with an excellent service.
You know,
they,
they uh,
they use the same service at sprint uses.
All right.
That's it.
That's the end of our podcast commercials.
Brian.
Oh,
Yay.
Kara.
Santa Maria is all up in this bitch and
she's ready to drop bombs on your mom's.
Fuck Carla experience.
Try my day.
Joe Rogan podcast my night.
Thank you very much for
coming on the podcast.
Really appreciate it.
Thanks for having me and bringing coffee.
Yeah.
Uh,
if you want some that's right.
They're calling your name.
It's tempting you.
I've had a bit too much
caffeine already today.
I think so.
All right.
Take a breather.
Oh,
have you?
How many times a day
do you allow yourself?
Caffeine?
Yeah,
twice a day.
I won't let myself any more than two.
I'm a junkie.
That's how I feel.
I feel like if you're having
like three cups of coffee,
four cups of coffee a day,
probably think I'm a real junkie too.
Cause I don't drink coffee much.
I drink like Coca Cola.
Is that worse for you?
Because of the sugar?
It's so much work,
but it has way less caffeine in it.
It's not even the sugar.
Right?
It's that corn syrup,
corn syrup,
but it has a lot less caffeine.
So why is it so delicious?
I love it.
Terrible for your brain.
So delicious.
All fizzy and your throat so good.
Especially if you have like a
meatball sub or something like that.
Oh my God,
Amit Paul solving a cold coke.
Oof.
It's like just don't drink them every day.
Yeah.
Every now and again you can get with what
my advice,
you know,
I have to say it's my vice because when
I quit I quit smoking cigarettes last
year I quit smoking weed
like a few years ago.
I haven't,
I don't drink.
Wow.
And so it's like,
do you do when you go off the rails?
Just coke some three or four.
I just,
I just yell a lot,
I guess.
I don't know.
I don't,
I don't really go off
the rails in that way.
No vendors for me.
I was in the jungle of of Mexico
on the way to a Cheech and EATSA.
I saw a big banner for coke on the wall.
There's this big poster
in the jungle coal.
Oh yeah.
It's like this jungle store.
I mean,
I'm telling you it's the Yucatan.
It's like where the Mayan ruins
are even deepen their coca cola.
It's ever,
I mean it is one thing you could travel
anywhere and know that you'll get a nice
cold coca cola.
Well sometimes it's not cold,
but
who would have ever
predicted that sugary water?
Right?
It'd be such a massive hit with humans.
I mean that is the craziest
fucking business ever.
We did 11 it's like anyone can do that.
Like what they're doing.
It seems like.
Why would that even be specific to
like one company while you're doing it?
Good.
Like I went to the store
and not to the store.
I went to have brunch with a friend the
other day and I asked for a coke and the
guy brought me a glass.
Yeah.
And I was like,
this coke is so gross.
What is wrong with it?
And like he got me another one
and then finally I was like,
I don't know,
I don't like it.
You have to take it back.
And he was like,
well it's Pepsi.
And I was like,
when I ask you for a coke,
don't bring me a Pepsi.
Wow.
Is it kind of sweat it kind
of still have the Cola Pepsi,
you fraud,
it's not as good.
Yeah.
I don't think Pepsi is
allowed to use cocaine.
I don't think coke is any more.
I know they do.
Well they don't.
They use the leaves and they
extract the flavor from there.
One of the biggest providers of cocaine
to some medical facility that uses it
for medical cocaine.
That's so funny.
Extraction plants like the extraction
plants and they take the whatever the
flavonoids that gives it this
particular coca cola flavor.
I bet it's just a little bit of cocaine.
That's probably what gives you the burn
to not enough test positive but enough
for your brain and know something's there.
Well and can we,
can we talk about how fucked up
that is by the way that like,
you know,
we,
I all the time I came from
the neuroscience world,
so many labs do cocaine research but
they can't do marijuana research because
it's schedule one like it makes no sense
to me that cocaine is viewed as having
medicinal purposes.
But things like ecstasy and marijuana and
acid don't have any medicinal purposes
whatsoever.
Yeah.
But like very few labs can
do research with those drugs.
It's a weird position in 2012 because the,
the propaganda that led to that position,
it's not really arguable anymore.
It's too silly.
Like if you look at the
actual facts of it and you go,
come on,
you guys are your,
this is archaic and then you realize
that it's not really about as much as it
the legality of these things and the
moving them into position for legality,
it's that that eliminates a huge business.
The business of keeping it illegal
police officers and like gigantic private
prisons and this pharmaceutical companies
alone would lose millions and millions
of dollars every year.
That's true.
A lot of people make money off of
the fact that marijuana is not legal.
Well,
at least federally still.
But I wonder why it is that cocaine is
not classified as a schedule one drug.
Who wants,
because they believe it has a medical
uses medical who gets prescribed cocaine?
I don't know.
Nobody does.
I mean,
they use it for,
they use it in lab research all the
time to study of reward pathways,
to study dopamine pathways.
And it's interesting because I think in
like in every day kind of layman common
parlance,
you'll hear people say all the time,
oh,
that's so similar to cocaine.
Oh,
You know,
when you fall in love and
then you have a breakup,
the withdrawal symptoms
are much like cocaine.
It looks like that in the brain.
Well,
why do you think we know that?
It's because we use cocaine
to study everything.
Like cocaine is such a model
kind of molecule that's
used in the laboratory with
laboratory animals.
Every lab does coke research.
Wow,
that's crazy.
It's,
it's a really,
really easy way to study kind of,
um,
reward pathways in the brain show,
as you said,
a couple of scripts,
uh,
for cocaine prescriptions.
No way
inside joke,
I guess.
Yeah.
Got me the fuck
Josie.
What?
I really believe you.
Yeah.
For half a second.
Like what?
No,
it is,
it's,
well,
it's kind of crazy that you
can get them for marijuana.
Marijuana is in such a
weird position right now.
I think there's like 18 different cities
or states rather than have made it
legal medically now
in Colorado,
made it legal recreation and we're
just just like a big fuck you to the
Washington state did as well.
Yeah.
Well,
it's,
it's just,
uh,
it's only a matter of time like
that the scales are tipping.
I mean,
and,
and Obama is,
doesn't have another term in front of him.
Hopefully he won't do what Clinton did,
which was after he got
voted out of office.
Oh,
you know,
I really think maybe it should be legal.
It's like,
oh,
maybe if you had a position of power
where you could do something about that
zap position is extremely costly,
I think to take that
position as a politician,
the only thing he gets from you for you
is the love of your constituents because
you're being honest.
That's the only thing it gets for you.
But what if Obama decides to
never go back to the Senate?
What if he decides to go
back to working for the,
you know,
as a public servant,
as a community organizer,
what does he have to lose?
Really?
Yeah.
What?
He doesn't have anything to lose.
So I want to see him like effect some
real change here in the second term,
I'm,
I would love to see that too,
but I just,
I know I'm a bit
disillusioned about it too,
but
they don't,
they don't ever seem
to be able to do that.
Even a guy like Obama,
just,
it was the perfect guy for if you wanted
to have a guy move into a position of
power like that,
that you thought would be
like a completely new face.
A guy who was born a
biracial of a single mother,
the whole deal came up,
poor,
worked hard,
it's very articulate,
didn't really have
anything wrong with them.
It's like a really bright guy,
a a lawyer.
Brilliant,
great speaker.
Perfect.
This guy's going to get used
to smoke while a lot of pot,
this guy's going to get an office,
she's going to sell
everybody the fuck down.
Yeah.
But then it gets in and it's like it,
it's almost like it's a job where
you don't get a chance to say what,
what really happened?
Yeah.
I mean it's,
it's probably really hard for us kind of
on the outside to know almost how much,
how,
how little power somebody actually
gets once they're elected in.
And,
and I mean,
obviously I think that we need to be
putting the pressure on Obama hardcore at
this point because I think that
he's made a lot of fucking mistakes.
And I think that he needs to
clean up a lot of messages,
especially with like civil rights abuses,
especially with a lot of the,
I mean,
well I won't say what I'm thinking.
Yeah,
exactly.
Civil liberties and I won't
say what I was about to say,
but um,
why not getting crazy?
I was about to go crazy,
so I'm going to dial it back a little.
But um,
but yeah,
I mean I think that at this
point it's kind of our job as,
as his constituency to
really put the heat on him.
I just don't know if there's
a really a president.
I don't know if it's real.
I don't know what I'm saying.
I have a feeling that that guy is
just working.
He's just,
I just think it's all so hard.
There's just too much money.
I think that's what it is.
There's just too much,
much too long and they don't
want to stop making it.
Yeah.
Even though it's a logical,
and everybody knows the logical,
they'll still like,
we've got to go to war with
Iran and everybody's like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Nobody wants to do it except the people
that can make a fuck load of money.
I think we're going to do it.
I don't think we're going to do,
I don't think we're going to do it.
No.
But I think that it would absolutely be
something that I wouldn't have to worry
about if Dick Cheney was in office.
I think you'd have to really
worried about us doing that.
Imagine a Pailin was an office.
I don't think they would let her talk.
I think they would figure
out a way to stop that shit.
Yeah.
They would figure out a way.
That one,
I think dial her down to
a reading shit off a tower
prompter.
Oh,
I just got a tweet.
Cocaine is used an eye surgery.
Oh yeah.
Cause it's an anesthetic.
Yeah.
Apparently there's a bunch of
different medical uses for dammit.
Shoving pencils in my eyes right now.
I've never done coke,
but I did do Lidocaine.
Yeah.
Um,
did have lighting.
I didn't do it like,
hey dude,
it's crazy.
But I had some in my body
because of the doctor.
I had my nose
start headed,
uh,
opened up.
I had a deviated Septum and they
spray this lidocaine up there,
which numbs the inside,
you know,
and it's,
it's makes you feel fucking terrible,
whatever it is.
Like he just gets in your
system and you're just like,
oh.
And apparently,
um,
people have died from putting
that shit on their legs.
Like people have had like girls that
wanted to get like their legs lasered.
Oh God,
that shit all over their
legs then wrap it up,
but Saran wrap and you overdose on this
line of Cain Shit and you can actually
die from it or not.
Maybe I should Snopes that Alba now,
but,
uh,
it,
I remember thinking how disgusting it was,
but it does numb the shit out of you,
which I guess,
uh,
apparently so does coke
does it Brian Coke.
Yeah.
Uh,
it makes,
it just makes me talk a lot.
I don't remember it numbing me though.
Cut.
Well,
I mean,
you can use it in your mouth.
Rubbing on your,
you know,
I saw,
have you seen Harold and
Kumar go to a Christmas one?
Oh,
there's a baby in it that's
doing cocaine and stuff.
And giving itself numbers and I
know how much you're like babies,
Joe,
I highly recommend that movie.
It's uh,
you're,
you're not a fan of babies.
Oh,
I love baby.
You love baby baby on coke.
If you like baby babies on
cocaine and doing ecstasy,
there's babies smoking weed,
doing ecstasy.
It's,
yeah,
it's the greatest thing in the
road that maybe he's hilarious.
See it in three d though.
Um,
apparently a lot of cane definitely kills
people and in fact that guy was using
it to a,
who was a murderer who used lidocaine.
He was injecting it into elderly patients.
Why?
To Kill Them.
Why did he want to murder
a bunch of elderly people?
I don't know.
It's like they're,
that that happens sometimes with nurses.
There's something really
weird that happens with nurses
or they resent their job
or whatever.
Take it out on the people.
It's not just that I think,
I think,
I think there's a w for a lot
of people dealing with trauma.
Yeah.
Regular basis over and over again can
give you some really twisted ideas about
life.
Watching so many people's lives.
Past is just totally my speculation,
but I would think that if you were fucked
up to begin with and you got into that
line of work,
the combination of the two,
like I had,
I had a friend who's,
he's an ophthalmologist and he did his
residency in Miami and it was during the
cocaine war days and he,
he's,
he would just come to me and just tell
me the shit that he saw and you would
just have to shake your head.
Like just people just
torn to bits blown apart,
stamped to death and he saw that
shit day after day sensitized to it.
I'm sure.
I mean,
how do you not?
And you want to have some power or some
excitement in your life so you're doing
something that you know is wrong but
you can't help yourself because it's a
thrill to see if he could pull
it off and they wind up doing,
it was like 2030 people
until they get Boston.
It's a sad,
there's been a bunch of cases like that.
All right.
This has been like a bummer conversation.
Yes.
This is kind of bumming me out.
Yeah,
it's,
we went from cocaine,
medical use of cocaine.
So like murdering old people.
Well,
like,
I don't know,
I don't want to turn her in a
nursing home and it's really sad.
Very
sensitive obviously because you,
um,
you said that you can't watch,
uh,
like MMA until you know the results.
I mean,
I have before,
it's definitely harder if
you know the person fighting.
Of course.
Right.
You're friends with Kang leads.
Yeah.
I'm,
I mean I'm,
I'm close to Kang Lee.
He is like best friends with somebody
who's really important in my life.
So I've gotten to be close to
him over about the last year.
Um,
and his last fight in China,
obviously I couldn't watch it live anyway.
Yeah.
But I kind of waited until I knew what
happened and then was really excited to
watch it,
but I don't want to see him get hurt.
Yeah.
He's a great guy.
Like he's,
he's got a great character.
That guy,
he's like so sweet.
He's amazing.
He's tough.
I mean,
a Burrito,
but you don't really,
you wouldn't know it.
Well,
you know,
which just my going in on the side.
Yeah.
Act like a tough guy.
No,
he's tough as fuck.
And he's 40 years old.
40,
you know,
like doing movies still and shit.
Yeah.
Well and he's kicking ass,
which is pretty crazy.
Yeah.
That's amazing.
I bet him mean he's doing both.
Like he's like,
he's,
I mean he's still pretty new in m and,
and um,
in UFC isn't he?
I mean,
he was a strike force for many years.
Yes.
Yeah.
He's only had a couple of fights.
He's had three fights in the
UFC now and I won his last two.
Right.
Yeah.
Awesome.
And he looks great.
Yeah.
I mean that the rich Franklin
fight was incredibly ridiculous.
I know it was one of the,
one of the best one punch knock outs ever.
And to do it to a guy like Franklin,
it's really impressive.
I wonder if it's fun.
A lot of people from like huge,
huge MMA fans.
I wonder,
is it more exciting or kind of a let
down when there's a knockout like in the
first row?
Um,
it's,
well,
you would,
you'd like to see a longer fight and
then knock out if you want to see like,
you know,
some people love to see just mastery.
Some people love to see a guy like
Anderson Silva just run someone over.
And some people like to see like
a Frankie Edgar Gray Maynard war.
Like everybody has their own,
like how they like to see fights play out.
Some people like to see someone
win and not get hurt at all.
But that's kind of a crazy
thing when Anderson Silva,
Anderson Silva does almost every fight.
I would prefer to see.
I,
yeah,
he wins and he never even gets hurt.
He fucks everybody up and it never even,
I mean,
he's the most ridiculous
example of a guy who wins,
like in spectacular fashion
and doesn't even get hit.
I just,
you know,
I think,
I think part of it for me is that,
you know,
when,
when it's somebody,
you know,
it's hard to see somebody take a punch.
It's hard to see somebody
break a bone or whatever.
But also I think because of my background
in the field that I come from and
studying neurobiology and working
with people with brain injury,
when I watched these fights,
that's all I can think
about the whole time.
It's like,
oh,
concussion,
oh God.
Twisted head in motion injury.
You know,
and I'm just so nervous for the fighters
cause it's just let's go in this ring
and get some brain injury.
Jason Smith,
someone's out there.
Oh,
I forgot to lock the front door.
Somebody here to see us.
No,
no.
Some random dude.
Ah,
um,
the,
uh,
the real issue isn't even
just the fights themselves,
it's getting prepared for the fights.
You know,
the,
uh,
the subconcussive trauma that you get
over and over and over again really piles
itself on even a little thug.
Yeah,
it's rough.
I,
I did a piece,
um,
for my column,
I do a video series that Huffington post
called talk nerdy to me every week I do
a video.
Um,
and one of the pieces really,
really early on that I did was about kind
of this concussive injury more in like
football players and boxers.
Um,
and the,
how it mimics als symptoms,
you know how it,
it starts to look like Lou
Gehrig's disease after a while.
And even though they think it's
kind of a separate disorder,
it has the same outcome,
which is so scary.
Yeah,
it's,
it's a,
it's a very scary guys have
to know when to get out there.
Really.
Do,
you got to know when they get out and
you have to get medical examinations and
stay up to date on all your,
you know,
all,
all your checkups and neurological
checkups and stuff like that because it's,
it's,
it's a,
it's a big gamble.
Yeah.
And that's why it's so exciting.
It's so exciting.
Nobody knows how much is on the line
and that's why nobody
wants to see huge changes.
Like in the NFL for example,
I actually got to be kind of Internet
friends with Steve Gleason after I did
that piece.
It was an ex NFL player who actually
suffers from these injuries now.
And he's got a foundation where he
really tries to educate people about it.
So we kind of tweet a lot,
but that's why I don't think you'll
ever see football players going back to
wearing leather helmets for example,
which would completely cut down on
concussive head injury is because people
wouldn't be charging with their head.
Yeah,
so hard for people to wrap
their heads around that.
The idea less padding
would actually be safer.
Exactly.
That's the argument.
Also for the UFC gloves you,
you,
you can't hit a guy as
many times you will eat.
You can't find them.
You'll break your hand and
hit him in certain spots.
It's one of the reasons why actually
bare knuckle fighting is probably the
safest way to do it.
It just looks so barbaric.
Tip does,
when you tighten up your fist and rapid,
you actually make it a better weapon.
You make it so it doesn't break as easily,
so you have to be less judicious
with where you know we're,
we're less accurate.
You can punch people in the arms
and not hurt your hands as well.
Yeah.
I always put my thumb in
the middle of of this.
That's just where my rings.
Just crazy gangster goth rings,
dragons and Shit.
Yeah.
I think the human body's
not really designed for it,
but it's the best way to
test the human character.
That's why it's so like
exciting viscerally.
You know,
like when you see a guy fight,
like you know everything about him,
you know,
you know what he's capable of,
like you know that when you see
someone like do something that's really
spectacular in an MMA fight,
the difficulty of doing that and pulling
that off on another train killer when
you watch like an Anderson Silva fight,
the spectacular nature that
he goes about doing that.
To me it's like the most exciting artwork
because I know how much is on the line
in order to create this performance.
But when he does it,
it's literally like a work of art.
Like I look at it the same
way someone would look at it.
Incredible sculpture.
Unfortunately,
I don't think
that everybody looks at it that way and
I think that it does just kind of have
this like Roman Coliseum,
you know,
draw to it,
which is just,
I want to see two people
fuck each other up.
I want to get my aggressions out
by watching somebody else do that.
I blame that on a lack of understanding
of a martial arts and I think that the,
the way to fix that would be to teach
it to everybody from the time they're
little kids.
And I think that should be a
curriculum in school for boys.
Well,
absolutely.
Yeah.
You can do martial arts without getting
a head injury when you're young.
You know,
you don't have to actually take a hit
because boys are angry and that's true.
Girls usually aren't that
random bitches though.
When they're young,
they're angry in different ways.
I'm more like chatty,
angry,
unless some girls are aggressive,
angry.
It's like those black chicks on Worldstar
hip hop.com I've never seen that.
You never know.
Are they aggressive?
Pull one up and watched some
girl get the fuck out of her.
That's impossible.
We might crash the Internet.
Listen,
I think.
I can imagine.
You can imagine.
You can imagine one of them.
You can't imagine the fucking beating
she puts on this girl and the speed and
when she does it,
it's so terrible and smiling now.
But if you actually show it to me,
it's going to be really
depressing what we want.
We don't have to live
this poor girl's misery.
But apparently some girl was talking shit
and so this girl came over her house.
She pulls her out of her house.
I mean within seconds
she's hit her 2030 times.
Just
then you're over and over and over.
Grabs her by her hair drags or
down the stairs and then says,
talk about dad.
Whoa.
It was a fight.
I can't,
that's hard for me to
empathize the way you look.
I haven't been in one since
I was a young boy myself,
but the,
the knowing how to fight with
protector from all that shit,
it wouldn't have happened.
She would have clinched,
ticking that girl down.
Headbutted her,
got her a Chubb put her out.
But if she knew how to defend herself,
she was attacked and she didn't
know how to defend herself with him.
That's why it was such a vicious beat.
I think there's this,
there's a switch in some
people's minds where,
where being on the defensive
feels like being on the offensive,
you know,
kind of as a thought experiment.
You know,
I'm very anti gun,
right?
Like I don't want to own a gun.
I don't want to see a gun.
I don't want to be near a gun.
And people always say,
yeah,
but what happens if somebody,
you know,
there's a home invasion armed,
what would you do?
And it's like,
I dunno.
I mean,
I know it sounds crazy,
but I might rather get shot than to
have to kill somebody to take somebody's
life.
Like I just don't think I could do it.
I don't think I could do it.
And I wonder if other people feel,
I mean,
most people have,
oh yeah,
fuck that.
I'm going to kill that guy before,
you know.
But I wonder if you're
actually faced with that,
if you,
if you would,
if you would want to.
That kind of survival instinct kicks in.
I think as humans we've kind of evolved.
We,
we've bred out
a lot of the survival instincts
that our ancestors had.
You know,
I,
we do fight to stay alive,
but for example,
if you look at the way
little kids grow up,
little kids need their parents for
years and years and years and years.
Like not until they're probably
in there maybe like just before they're
10 11 could they even maybe survive on
the streets?
And even then,
that would be tough,
you know?
But definitely a four year old,
a five year old could never figure out
how to feed themselves to take care of
themselves.
Whereas if you look in the animal kingdom,
it's within months that
most animals are weaned.
We just,
we weave in order to,
I think have these more complex thoughts
and these more complex abilities.
As humans,
we have language and we have art and
we have music and we have philosophy.
We're not so good at the
survival stuff anymore.
And I dunno,
I just,
I don't feel that drive in me.
And I think that if faced with death
or what I would consider to be murder,
even if it was in self defense,
I dunno.
Well that's a tough decision
either you and your own
individual point of view,
which is extreme and well thought out
or I don't think that's represented.
It might.
Yeah,
it's probably,
it's probably not.
I wonder how many girls
would say the same thing.
It's pretty rare.
I think so.
Yeah.
I think you're,
you're,
I don't think that's your position
has represented by most people.
Maybe not.
Most people will like tell you about like,
fuck that.
I'm going to kill that guy.
Incredible things they've
done to stay alive.
Yeah,
no,
that's true.
And I bet you you do have that
instinct that really does kick in.
Like,
you know,
I'm the guy who cut off his own arm,
from 127 thank you.
Would too.
I might,
I might cut off.
You're,
I think you're,
the way you're looking at it is looking
at it in the way of a person who just
does not have it in them to harm a person.
You don't have it in there.
I might not,
I don't know.
But you have to take into consideration
that human beings are so fucking complex
that sometimes one of us goes off the
rails into the woods and needs to be put
down.
And you know what?
I'm not a mother.
I wonder if I had a child,
if,
if that whole idea would change because
all of a sudden if I'm not protecting
myself,
but I'm protecting,
you know,
my,
my child,
that all of a sudden I'd become like
this crazy bitch and I would defend
anything to the desk.
Be Protecting the fact that your child
would be horrified if you weren't around.
That's true.
Yeah.
That's something that you think
of when you were growing up.
Um,
yeah.
You would fight to the death.
Do you have kids?
Yes,
you do.
And you have that like,
oh,
the tents instinct to protect them.
Oh,
it's crazy.
It's a crazy instinct.
Do you love them so much?
I mean it's,
it's really hard to understand.
Yeah.
I just thought I understood
it because of dogs relative.
Yeah.
I've got a dog who I love,
but like,
Eh,
can I,
I'm like on a drug when I
play with my two year old,
it's like a drug.
Yeah.
No.
And my four year old
is like a little human.
We have like little conversations
about things about life.
We talk about stars.
Yeah.
And they're still like the
sooner the inner science,
the four year old is into everything.
Yeah.
She's,
she's really,
I feel like little kids
are little scientists.
That's the coolest thing about them is
that they have just this kind of natural
instinct to think scientifically about
the world and they want answers to
everything.
They just explore everything and
they're not satisfied either.
If you give them an answer
that does not satisfy them,
they'll be like,
not good enough.
But why
I have,
I've had the boat why conversation like
over and over and over again as to why
people live in cities and why some
people don't live like we were driving.
To the mountains like,
well,
why are these people living
in the place like this?
How come they don't want
to live in the city?
You know,
I want to live in the city.
Well,
they're trying to figure out like
where is there a good place to live?
Like the four year olds are going like,
is this this thing?
Where's the spot to live?
It's like,
she's like,
it seems like you can live it a lot of
fucking pot and seeing like a four year
old put that together.
It's a,
it's a,
it's a mind fuck
and you're absolutely right.
That was a brilliant way of putting it
in that they're like little scientists
because they have to be,
they're trying to piece together
their view of the world from scratch,
you know?
Yeah.
Can you imagine going back,
I feel that like have you,
have you ever done acid?
No,
I've never,
nobody in the room.
I used to sell bibles of it.
I think that that's the draw for some
people when they do psychedelics.
But I would say specifically LSD as,
as compared to other psychedelics because
one of the central features that I
always found,
and I haven't done anything like
that since late high school,
early college,
but one of the central features
that I always found was that you,
everything's kind of new again,
like you don't really understand
why things are the way they are.
Like you'll find yourself staring at
your hand for 20 minutes going like,
I have fingers and they
move and I can grab things.
Holy Shit.
And um,
and yeah,
I remember one time a friend driving
somewhere far away with a bunch of,
were all on acid and it was like,
we have to,
we had to get gas.
And it was like the weirdest
thing because money,
these pieces of paper have value.
Like it was very confusing to everybody,
but it was,
it was such an,
it's always such an
interesting experience to,
you know,
everything's so new and you have to
piece it together and make sense of the
world around you.
And of course you have epiphany after
it just constantly epiphany's like you
just think that you're the most brilliant
person in the world because you're
figuring everything out and you document
it and you sober up the next day and
you're shitting herself.
Crying could be,
but I've never had,
I've never had one of those terms.
[inaudible] Columbus,
Ohio,
the worst,
the worst trip that I had was a
really long trip and it was just,
I was grimy and I was just over it and
I was trying to sober up cause I had to
work the next day and I hadn't slept.
And when I was younger I used to
dye my hair a lot of crazy colors.
I kept it really short and dyed it a lot.
It's a little like punk
rocker raver chick.
And I remember taking a shower cause I
thought it would sober me up and my hair
was like blood red.
And so I took the shower and wash my
hair and just all this red shit was going
down the drain and it
really flipped me out.
But it was so late in the trip
that I worked my way through it.
I've never had a scary
like shitting myself trim.
That sounds awful.
Yeah.
I knew
a couple people that had lost a fucking
minds on drugs when I was a kid,
so I was really hesitant
until I was in my thirties.
I never even smoked pot.
I had a friend who,
uh,
was in my neighborhood who sold coke
and I've watched him go from this like
carefree,
fun,
loving guys.
Always fun to be around.
Yeah.
To being this withered away.
Weird.
Well,
yeah,
those are two very different drugs.
She's hiding in his attic
and doing coke all the time.
It's like girls,
I mean,
coke is,
is similar.
It's weaker,
but it's similar to math and you see,
I mean,
math is like the most disgusting
compound on the planet.
I mean,
it fucks people's lives up.
What do you wait
gun this m d p v stuff
that McAfee was accused.
I don't really know anything
about it to be honest.
I haven't taken the
time to really study it.
I mean it sounds kind of nuts but that's,
you know,
that's what people do is they find the
newest compound and because a lot of
times you can get things more readily
you their legal until kind of the feds
catch on to it and they
have to start outlining it.
When I was growing up,
we used to do um,
uh DXM all the time dextromethorphan
cause you could get it in,
in over the counter cough
medicine and it was like weed,
ketamine,
Robo Turban,
robot tripping or we would take chorus
sit in which were the little red pills,
little red devils and yeah,
I mean and and it's a
dissociative anesthetic.
It like no totally fucks you up.
You take it annually or did
you take it through your mouth?
We took it orally.
We prefer her to just shut them up and
cause they would dissolve in your ass.
Yeah.
That's,
that sounds like a boy.
How many of your girlfriends
did that with you and
believe that?
I believe that don't get to put like
tampons soaked and vodka like that's
gotten really sick from that.
I try.
It's a bit drunk.
Pussy.
Can you imagine?
Uh,
that's really,
that's the real term.
Drunk Pussy,
that's what they call it.
But boys,
they have to do it in their ass strongly.
The tech knows what I
do tampons with Tampa.
Well that it's,
it's probably smoke tampon.
It makes the most sense.
I mean yeah to be honest.
But just do girls do it in their
ass or do they do in their vagina?
No,
it sounds like it would burn.
I think they're doing in their vagina.
You're right.
Yeah.
She'll make no,
she's got one.
I've got one of the day.
It sounds like it would burn.
It would probably be burned on the other
thing that probably just all around the
store.
And why would you put vodka in your be
cause I get your drinks so much that you
can't get drunk.
Dude.
You know how fucking
crazy do you have to be
to be like you know what?
Fuck shots.
It's got to go on by.
Yeah,
I know.
You will get great if man,
how the fuck,
how like self destructive
do you have to be?
I know what you have to be young and dumb,
but why in your ass?
I don't,
I never,
I never put any drugs up my ass,
but I do remember like snorting a,
you know,
an ecstasy tablet.
Like why did I need to start it?
Why couldn't I just swallow?
It was again,
I wasn't going to hit me fast enough.
You know?
It's like we do stupid shit when,
yeah,
sure.
Snorting
Adderall.
That's another thing.
I remember going to this party and all
the girls were snorting Adderall because
they couldn't get coke and,
okay.
Wow.
That's so crazy.
What did they do,
like clean the house and do her homework.
Bad idea at a party.
I've never done that.
Are All either.
Right.
My friend,
the late great Robert Schimmel told me
that he took one accidentally once and
Robert had a health conditions,
you know,
he had cancer for awhile.
Yeah.
Um,
and so,
you know,
he didn't know if this is like
dangerous for him to take.
So he calls his doctor
and his doctor said,
listen,
it's just,
you took it,
you're going to be fine.
But you know you're on a
ride for the next 12 hours.
Yeah,
and he goes,
I got so much.
Oh,
okay.
I was like,
I cleaned my office,
I organize my notes.
I was putting them into
folders and categories.
It's like subtle meth behavior.
Yeah,
it really is.
And that's the thing.
These kids take it every day.
They take it every day.
They're on low levels of math every day.
Oh my God.
It's perfectly legal.
And their parents tell them to though
you behave much better when you're on
this,
you know?
And I mean,
it's nuts.
I've never been one,
you know,
like I said,
I haven't done drugs in many,
many years,
but when I did do drugs,
I wa I was much more
into downers than uppers.
Like uppers make made me jittery.
That made me feel like
shit and I couldn't sleep,
which I hated.
I love drugs that you could
just follow us expression.
Okay.
I have,
I have done,
ketamine was correct.
I did not like it.
I hate it.
Yeah,
I snorted it.
I did not like it at all.
I felt so sick.
I was in,
I went into a hole for a little bit.
I felt so sick.
I was lying on my bed with a friend
of mine and we were just like,
we had our,
like we were touching kind of,
but it would be like if you move,
I'm gonna throw up and if I move,
you're gonna throw up and you just,
you sit there and you flow.
I remember floating around my apartment
kind of listening to other people's
conversations.
Did it seem like everything was like slow?
Like I tried to walk
upstairs and it was like,
and it was,
it was horrible.
I just remember thinking like,
this is not fun.
Like what?
But all of my friends who did it,
they used to do it.
You know?
I only tried it the one time and they
did just as much as I did and they were
just totally normal.
I mean that,
you know,
you build up a tolerance,
they're just walking around like,
man,
it's fun to be on Ketamine.
Yeah.
Uh,
it becomes addictive.
Yeah.
And I'm glad that I hated it then.
I knew one guy who lost his life to
it and it was going up was an MMA guy.
Um,
he is somehow or another got addicted
to it when I can see that too because it
really numbs the pain.
Like I think that's why people like you
don't feel anything when you're on it.
But there's the issue though
for me was that I'd like,
there's other guys that have taken
it recreationally and had these crazy
experiences on it,
but I think they do it intramuscularly
so they can do like a much lower dose
probably.
I don't know.
It's a lower
because if you take too much ketamine,
you can't move.
It paralyzes.
Yeah.
Lily used to take judge John Lilly,
the um,
the,
the guy who invented the isolation tank,
he used to take it and go into the tank.
I could see that because then you
wouldn't be able to feel anything,
right?
Yeah.
Oh God,
that sounds Todd warming.
Tom McCormick mix.
First
trip in the tank.
He,
he,
he took a trip
and Lily's tank,
lily put them in the
tank and then Lily said,
you do you want ketamine with this?
And it was like,
well,
fuck it.
I gotta say yes.
John Lilly asked me if
I want to do ketamine.
He goes,
all right,
here you go.
Boom.
He stabs him in the leg with it,
hits the plunger and sends him to
the fucking darkest of the universe,
will only get an isolation tank
the first time ever doing ketamine.
Okay.
Jimmy,
if he also have a
dolphin fucking tank too,
that you fucked off,
isn't it?
No,
no,
no.
Lily did not
fucked off.
But what he did do that was,
that's what it is.
Private diary said no,
no,
no.
Brian,
you're so confused.
You don't know the real history.
What is happening right now?
Info wars.com ladies and gentlemen,
that's what's happening.
No,
but what he,
he was,
uh,
the reason why Brian saying that he did
do a lot of experience with dolphins.
He actually was a pioneer maybe
with tree species communication.
He was like trying to figure out dolphin
languages and stuff and the way he was
doing it was on acid for real.
Okay.
And with isolation tanks and at one point
like you put an isolation tank right
next to a dolphin tank was
trying to communicate with them.
Yeah.
It's,
it's pretty funny how like this,
this is the definition of bad science
right here is like all of these
experiments on acid,
every card,
my findings and tell people I talked to
that,
it's like we'd have,
Nah,
we can't,
like we,
there's not an app where you can go
to the zoo and talk to the doctor.
No,
exactly.
Yeah.
We don't really know what the fuck,
how do we know his research is valid?
And he's like,
well,
you know,
three chirps means he's happy.
Exactly.
And,
and definitely not reliable because I'm
sure nobody else has been able to repeat
those studies.
Well,
Dolphin noises are real weird one for us.
There's so alien,
like the sound is so alien and bizarre
and for us to even wrap our head around
the fact that that it's a language,
like it's not a language.
Yeah.
Rest of way,
the way,
you know,
the,
the English language is structured or,
or the sounds that we,
we make with our NOI,
with our mouths.
Yep.
But they're communicating and
they're also doing echo location,
you know,
which is really cool.
And it's,
I think it's so cool when
you see a dolphin or a bat
doing echolocation so that
they can get around.
It's really interesting to think about
the fact that some humans who are,
who have been blind,
it typically congenitally blind.
I'm blind from birth,
can actually do that.
Echolocation there's some great youtube
videos of one kid who could skateboard.
I mean he could do everything.
He actually since then passed away,
I think he had a stroke.
But I mean he was a fascinating person
because he had just such evolved
echolocation skills.
He would just click and he could hear,
he could just sense them,
I should say sense not even here.
Yeah.
Cause there's probably so much
more heightened than just hearing.
Just sense them bouncing back to him
constantly and nowhere he was in space
from,
it's,
it's so fascinating how there are,
you know,
perceptual things that we
probably completely take
for granted because we have
eyes or because we have ears,
that organisms that are much kind of
behind us on the evolutionary timescale
can utilize that are just probably,
you know,
kind of latent in us.
And if for some reason we
lose some sort of ability,
we could,
you know,
develop something like echo location and,
and use it to our advantage.
Just most people would never
think to do it because we can see.
So we don't need to.
And seeing is a much more advanced
way to navigate your surroundings.
We should tape a bunch of
bats to some dolphins guy.
Fuck the bats first where it had the
basket in this context because they,
yeah,
they use the echo location.
But I'm speaking of like reluctant often
going back to drugs when you said that
this guy like ketamine for the first time,
the isolation tank,
the first time I ever did,
um,
GHB.
Has Anybody here ever done she HV yes.
The first time I ever did we actually
we were doing lactone like a friend of
ours made it.
So it was like,
I think the precursor did Ghb,
but the first time I ever
tried it I was also on ecstasy
and I was at my friend's apartment
and a hell of a fucking party.
I do,
but I really wasn't.
I've just had some crazy
experiences here in California.
Grew up in Texas.
Yeah.
What is there to do in tech?
Like a suburb of Dallas called Plano.
And I remember a friend of my being in
a friend's apartment doing acts and then
trying GHB and um,
and just sitting there like,
I mean,
I was trash out of my mind
and we're all sitting there.
It's really quiet.
And then they started playing as the
first time I'd ever heard the band.
Mr Bungle.
I love,
I love my patents,
but um,
but it like,
it was the weirdest experience of my,
if you've never listened to Mr Bungle,
like imagine listening to
Mr Bungle on like heavy,
heavy doses of ecstacy and Ghb.
Mr Bunk.
Love.
Mr [inaudible].
He also did a,
I got a
tweet yesterday that was
like directed to both of us.
It was like Joe
because I was pretty outspoken about
mixing them up
a bill that they were trying to pass our
proposition or proposition that they're
trying to pass as the labeling
initiative for Gmos in California.
And I voted against the labeling
initiative and all of my liberal,
cause I'm,
I'm super liberal.
I'm,
you know,
I'm not even a democrat.
I would call myself just
a progressive independent.
And the funny thing is though that I
find like on my column on Huffpost,
I write about science.
Fundamentally.
I am pro science.
I'm pro reason I'm anti religion.
I'm a strong atheist.
It's tied into my,
my views with science and my views
about some of these things like animal
research or like genetically
modified organisms.
They are informed by my studies
of the scientific literature.
They're not informed by my
party affiliation or you know,
by my,
um,
my political views.
So that's where sometimes,
you know,
generally I think scientific thinkers and,
and left wingers are in the same camps.
But once in awhile I think
you have these leftwing,
anti-science views or pseudoscience views
that that come up against each other.
So I'm very,
and you believe that genetically
modified food is that
I think that genetically
modified organisms are
extremely important and I think
that we probably don't realize
how much of them we already eat.
Like 70% of the food on the shelves
in the grocery store is genetically
modified.
And I'm not against labeling our food.
Don't get me wrong.
When I voted against
the labeling initiative,
I wasn't voting against
putting a label on food.
I was voting against the way that
the voting initiative or the labeling
initiative was presented.
I don't think that it should
be a local initiative.
I think that it should be a federal
initiative and I think that it's arbitrary
to choose GMO as the thing that we're
gonna all suffer from if we don't label it
on our food.
What do you believe is the,
what's most important about
genetically modifying foods?
Why is it so important?
Why?
What is the misconception?
Cause my,
my conception of it has always
been my perception of it.
Rather reading articles that a lot of
people are concerned with the longterm
consequences of eating certain foods that
have been significantly changed to the
point where they can resist pesticides.
They have all these strange a antibiotic
properties and they worry about the
long term consequences of
consuming these unnatural foods.
Okay.
So,
so I think two points that I can
make it in direct response to that.
I think it's fair to say that they're
worried about long term consequences
because they haven't been around long
enough to see those consequences.
But so far every legitimate lab
experiment that has been done has shown no
deleterious effects.
The big rat study with
the tumors has been,
you know,
completely debunked.
Like there's just,
it's just bad science.
Well,
no,
it's,
it was bad science because the truth is
the types of rats that they were doing
the study on 10 bitch ass routes,
they tend to get tumors anyway.
And so they weren't really doing a good
job of comparing the controls to the
experimental model there.
But so,
so his lab animals,
no,
there's no evidence.
I mean,
just good evidence.
Everybody's freaking out
because they're going well,
it dangerous,
so it could be dangerous.
And so that that first
of all makes me worried.
And then also I think,
I think it's the,
the lexicon that we use,
it's this natural versus unnatural.
There's kind of like whole foods is better
because it's all natural and just the
word natural is like
hilarious to me because
organisms,
especially plants,
mostly what we're talking about here
at plants like fruits and vegetables,
they have been genetically modifying
them selves for hundreds of thousands of
years.
They swap jeans all the time.
And then once agriculture began,
we started genetically modifying all of
these organisms by doing crossbreeding.
We would take,
you know,
the healthiest looking tomatoes and read
it only with the other really healthy
looking tomatoes.
And what we were really
doing is solidifying that
certain genes we're going to
be passed down and other genes
we're going to be weeded out.
Now what we do is we,
we put individual genes into the plant.
So whereas we used to swap something like
50,000 genes without even knowing the
specifics of what we were changing.
Now that we can do it with
biotechnology in the lab,
we can swap out one or two genes and
somehow that's more frightening to the
general public.
Then 50,000 genes being swapped and
so that's the part that I don't really
understand people's arguing.
So when you're coming at it,
you're coming at it,
you think from a position of science
where you say the evidence against it is
really,
most of it's just confused.
I think that it's a lot.
There's a lot of
fearmongering first of all,
and the truth is if you don't want
to eat GMOs because you're not sure,
you don't have to trust me.
The companies that don't use genetically
modified organisms and their food
already labeled their packages as such
because they use it as a marketing ploy,
right?
They're not going to
miss out on that chance.
So for us to have to mandate a label that
says this is genetically modified food
is really going to come across to
the regular consumer as warning.
This is genetically modified food.
When there's no reason to warn people.
The FDA's job is to warn people
if there's a potential risk,
there's no risk of eating GMOs.
And all the evidence so far says
that they're perfectly healthy.
What about the,
the Chinese studies that show that a,
it's not just vitamins
and protein that some,
uh,
Gmos are providing to the body but
your body is absorbing micro RNA.
I Dunno,
I'd be interested.
I haven't read those studies.
I'd be interested to see it,
but I would also be interested to
see if non GMOs are also doing that.
Yeah,
that's a good point.
Yeah.
I mean it's,
you know,
it's,
it's a tough situation
and the truth is that um,
scientists aren't monolithic on this.
Not all scientists agree.
Many scientists voted to label,
but isn't the real issue that if there
is something wrong and especially in the
future,
if it's well,
you know,
shortens people's lifespans
some ways causes some problem,
it's going to be really hard to
stop once it's already in place
it,
but it already is in place.
That's the thing.
I mean,
it's not like not labeling it now,
it's going to make it be more in place.
We're already eating 70% of our food
is already genetically modified.
And you don't think there's any danger?
I'm not concerned about it.
I'm really not.
And you what the truth is in essence,
it helps people in.
Sometimes I worry if these kinds of
conversations that I would be having,
like when I would do,
um,
appearances on the
young Turks for example,
which I think is a really
great network and I,
I'll,
I'll sit on with them a lot just
to kind of talk science with them.
But there's a very strong liberal view
on the shows and so a lot of the people
will write in and they'll
ask about these things.
And I think that sometimes,
I know it might sound
a little bit offensive,
but it's kind of like
a first world problem.
Like it's kind of like a 1% or problem
to be worrying about eating these
genetically modified organisms.
The reason that,
um,
farmers,
the reason that biotechnologists in,
in these university laboratories are
doing genetic modification is so that we
could feed more people
safely and healthily so that
people who don't have access
to a lot of nutritious food can eat,
for example,
golden rice that gives them certain
vitamins that they wouldn't have been able
to get if they were
just eating white rice.
It's so that these foods can have a
longer shelf life so that they last longer
so that more people can consume them.
But we're looking at it through American
eyes from an American perspective where
we constantly waste food,
where we have so much
money that we can eat.
You know,
we,
we try to make our food as
clean as possible and I mean,
that's fair.
And I'm not shitting on people
who want to eat pure organic food,
but I don't like the holier than thou
attitude that somehow they're healthier
because they do it because there's
no evidence to support that.
That's my stance.
Well,
you know,
it seems like you've thought this
through a lot more than I have.
Um,
my,
uh,
my views on it,
I've always been,
uh,
that if you look under
genetically modified foods,
uh,
look online,
the majority,
the vast majority of
the articles about it,
our danger articles.
So you feel like that's all just
scare mongering and just trying to,
I think a lot of it is,
and you know,
I think that also there's this,
this idea that well,
if Monsanto is in on it,
it must be evil.
And I get that because
Monsanto is an evil,
evil company.
But I also think that we need to separate
in our minds the difference between
bad business practices and
greedy capitalistic practices
and the basic science
that goes into it.
And it's,
I know it's hard to do,
it's hard to separate those things,
but just because I voted no and,
and Monsanto voted no,
doesn't mean that I'm in bed
with Monsanto for example.
But I do see it seems like
an easy thing to do to go,
oh,
Monsanto's for this.
Well then I'm automatically against it,
you know?
I mean,
it makes sense to me,
honestly,
of all the other arguments.
That's the argument that
I appreciate the most.
Like when people go,
I voted for it because Fuck Monsanto.
I'm like,
man,
okay,
I'll give you that.
If anybody needs to do
mushrooms and look at the life,
it's the people that run Monsanto.
I agree.
The suicides that are connected
to them just in India alone.
It's terrifying.
It's that hundreds of thousands
of people who couldn't pay off.
There's their seeds.
Couldn't afford to run their farm.
Yeah,
it's disgusting.
I mean,
and talk about like a civil liberties,
a human rights issue right there.
Yeah.
It is crazy
number like the,
I'll just pull
it up right now and be in suicides
due to Monsanto cause it's true.
It's fucking,
yeah.
And it's so sad because I
feel like so many hardworking,
you know,
university scientists who don't get a
dime from companies like Monsanto are
working really hard to manipulate these
organisms for the reason of helping
people,
you know,
in order to feed more people
that are going hungry and for,
for some of that research
to become bastardized.
Um,
once this huge company can kind of put
restrictions on people's ability to get
food or grow food and
their own indigenous,
you know,
in their end the farms in their backyards,
it's just,
that's so sick and you know what,
instead of doing this,
if they just provided them a bit,
a more reasonable rate,
uh,
in a more reasonable way and
worked with these farmers,
they would continue to get
a certain amount of money
from them instead of raping
this,
like taking it off.
They could have a,
a nice business with these people and
continue to profit and everybody do well,
but they have connected 200,000 suicides
in India throughout the past decade to
Monsanto.
That's so,
that's so fucked up.
Crazy so far.
I mean it's also 200,000
people if you think about it,
who are no longer working and making money
and these are 200,000 people
who are probably very poor
and probably could never
raise enough money to live you a
legitimate lawsuit against this company.
And I mean it's,
it's just,
it's mortifying and it's
the same thing that we see,
I feel like with big Pharma,
and this is another big problem where,
um,
people will lump in biomedical research,
the lump in research on drug
efficacy with big Pharma.
And there are,
don't get me wrong,
there are a lot of connections there.
And,
but what's wrong,
I think with the way that drugs
are prescribed in this country,
what's wrong with the amount of kind of
danger linked to drugs in this country
has little to do with the fact that
drugs are being developed that can help
people.
And it has everything to do with
how these drugs are being marketed.
We're the only developed country in the
world where we can have commercials for
pharmaceuticals on television because
we shouldn't be asking our doctor,
if so and so is right for us.
Our doctors should be telling
us what we should be taking.
Right.
You know,
we should and we should have the ability
to take generics of things if we want
to.
We,
you know,
drug should be affordable for people.
I mean I'm,
I'm for universal health care.
I definitely think that that would
change a lot of these problems.
But again,
I think that a lot of
liberal thinkers who,
they,
they end up throwing the baby out with
the bath water and they throw the science
out with the,
with the terrible company practices.
And,
and that is kind of sad to me because I
think the fundamental science is being
done to develop drugs that
actually help people is amazing.
It's crazy that they tell you what
would be wrong with you if you need the
stuff.
Yeah.
And then you go to,
you talked to like,
dude,
I got that same problem.
Yeah.
I'm thinking I need this stuff.
Like they,
it's so unfair because all those people
in those commercials have got their shit
together.
They're holding hands,
they're walking together on the
beach and everybody's smiling.
I mean,
I saw a commercial the other day for it,
for a drug
for CLPD medicine.
Copt is chronic obstructive
pulmonary disease.
That's bronchitis and emphysema combined.
And the woman's like,
now that I take my medicine,
I can do every,
and I'm like,
no,
that woman would hardly be
able to get off the couch.
Even if you're medicated for CLPD,
your life is really tough.
You can't breathe,
you cannot breathe.
And this chick was just running around.
She's just like,
I'm fine now that I take
my inhaler or whatever.
And it's like,
people know if you have CLPD,
you know what your options are,
you're suffering and you've talked
to your doctor about how to fix this,
you know.
And so to have all of that information
readily available by your physician,
I think is important.
But to advertise it on television,
how did they make them through?
How did that become a
reality in modern America?
Lobbies in Congress.
Yeah.
It's really incredible.
Some of the shit that's legal.
I know.
It's really strange.
It's,
it's,
it's like depressing.
It's really depressing.
It just,
in this day and age we have the w with
the access to information that we have.
The,
the culture hasn't really caught
up to what everyone knows.
Yeah.
So the reality of what
everyone knows about,
you know,
the insanity of the,
the economy and how it's all structured.
The reality of drug laws,
the reality of law enforcement and the
reality of like ever increasing civil
liberties violations where
people have to fight for what,
you know,
used to be what we consider it
a part of being an American.
Yeah.
Uh,
proud to be an American because
at least I know I'm free.
You're supposed to be free.
This is not supposed to be a place
where someone's looking at every fucking
email you send and listening to
every phone call you make this,
it's not supposed to be that.
And even outside of America.
I mean,
that's,
I think a really sad part of the civil
liberties violations is like looking at
just the sheer amount of like bombings
and drone strikes we'll replace with
innocent deaths just across the board.
Um,
and to see us do the same type of tactics,
even in a lesser form.
Then we're seeing that we're seeing
dictators doing other countries like Egypt
where the people are riding in the streets
because this guy has turned himself
into a dictator.
Yup.
We're,
we're seeing those incremental steps
right behind the cover of darkness.
You feel do certain bills over
at least so on New Year's Eve.
So everybody has to go back
and it's our guy.
It's not Dick Cheney.
You know what I mean?
That's our guy.
He couldn't be doing that.
Well,
they're not publicizing
that he's doing that,
but they are.
I mean,
it's,
it's rough.
But I,
you know,
restraint Obama has taken,
uh,
taken a lot of this Patriot Act shit
that Bush put into play and just amped it
up.
So the drownings amped up the dronies,
the warrantless wiretapping and you know,
the idea that they could detain
American civilians with no recourse.
You can't get a lawyer.
You can't talk to anybody about it.
They don't have to let
anybody know where you are.
They don't have to inform your
family that they can just take you.
That's insane.
You know,
we do have the internet at our fingertips.
I have my iPad right here and I've got
my iPhone and I'm looking at Twitter and
I can constantly access anything I want,
but it's as easy to read an article on
politico as it is to go to like lol cats.
You know what I mean?
And exactly.
And so I think that,
yeah.
Was that like a lame
out of date reference?
Do people still go to like [inaudible]
this shit at one point in time,
remember everybody was like,
Oh my God,
this is so cute.
This is so cute.
But terrible resolution.
I'd rather,
I mean sometimes I would rather watch
a bad lip reading than an actual,
you know,
presidential debate or
something on Youtube.
So
get offended as an intelligent person
when you hear politicians talk in that
political bullshit way.
Oh hell yeah.
You should wait until,
I just want to tell everybody at,
please log on on Monday to huff post
science because I'm releasing a new video
where I just like rail into Marco Rubio.
I rail into Marco Rubio is the senator
from Florida who was interviewed by Gq
recently and just kind of hemmed and
hawed when they asked him how old is the
earth?
And instead of saying up
front 4.5 billion years,
he said,
Whoa,
I'm not a scientist.
And I can't really say,
and there's a lot of debate
with theologians and stuff.
Well there is a lot of debate
between theologians and scientists.
Yeah,
that is true.
There's a lot of debate
between why knows and cops
also true
this bridge.
And it's not just that,
you know,
I ran into some of the guys that
recently got voted out of office.
I'm like Walsh and Akin,
I talk about super political,
your phone,
all this nonsense,
especially when when
science comes into this,
this Guy Brown who sits on the fucking
house science committee and he thinks
that,
um,
evolution,
embryology and all this nonsense about
the Big Bang theory are lies from the pit
of hell is what he said publicly
in front of a wall of deer heads,
by the way.
Um,
I mean it's,
it's mortifying that these people,
there are so many global warming deniers,
evolution deniers who were sitting on the,
on the House Committee for Science Space
and technology and these people have
jurisdiction over the National
Science Foundation over NASA,
over,
um,
uh,
the US agricultural service.
I mean,
it's so scary and they're all just
fucking Republican Texan oil money,
you know,
lobbies are lining their pockets.
It's so scary.
Are we going to have this conversation?
I was a little nervous about this
because I saw some tweets coming in.
Well,
you know,
it's a fascinating thing because for
whatever reason it's become this sort of
right wing talking points and it's,
it's like something that people get
like real reactionary with and they get
real,
they have like a built in,
uh,
instead of reactionary.
They have a built built
in answer and you know,
someone brings up what
about global warming?
It's a cycle to
natural cycle happens all the time.
And these guys are called pseudo science,
but it's this weird aggressive like
right when then because it's become so
politicized.
So like 99.9% of scientists agree that
the earth is getting warmer and that
human carbon emissions are a highly
contributing to this right now.
How the fuck does that an emotional issue?
Like what?
What is,
what is that?
It's so funny how many of these you
start to see these people flip flopping
lately because they can't hold
on to this kind of archaic,
you know,
just embed it seeped in
such intense religion.
They can't hold onto these views anymore.
We saw Pat Robertson the other day
on the 700 club like Pat Robertson,
the televangelist,
the old guy going on about like
a woman wrote in and she said,
I'm nervous because my kids asked me
about dinosaurs and I don't know how to
tell them to make it legit with the Bible.
And I really want them to be
with me in the Kingdom of Heaven.
And Pat Robertson's all this business
about the earth being 6,000 years old is
crazy talk.
All the science says that it's old.
We know it's 4.5 billion years old.
We have radio carbon dating man.
Never lived with dinosaurs.
We have frozen dinosaur.
He said we have frozen dinosaur carcasses
and the Dakotas and thank God for Pat
Roberts.
I just thank God for path in which I do
not believe for Pat Robertson because
he's,
I mean granted he's still a total piece
of work and he said earlier this year
that atheist are trying to steal
Christmas and I'm very concerned,
hey,
don't take Christmas away from me.
Christmas was for the Pagans first.
So fuck all y'all
a fire circle.
That sounds like fun.
But
I will say that I am still happy.
Then Pat Robertson came out
more bizarre than the global warming one.
It's an aggressive one.
Natural Cycle.
They've got ice core samples.
It's like that typical,
typical,
that
weird conservative talk show
radio guy voice solution.
Well we just need to allow kids to
learn all the different options and they
tried to go about it
kind of in a smarter way
in this video on Monday.
And I basically talk about why creationist
and then I take you back all the
way to the beginning of time,
6,000 years ago and
there's like whole fucking
all over the globe.
You know,
like humans have been evolving for
hundreds of thousands of years and there's
beautiful pottery and boats and plows.
There's agriculture.
People are doing math already fishing
that anybody could believe that the earth
is only 6,000 years old.
It's just a huge block.
That's what it is.
It's like it's cognitive dissonance.
They know it has to be older
because they've been to a
museum and they've read a
textbook,
but they have to,
they feel guilty.
There's this guilt that's built
into their faith that says,
I don't know if I don't believe this,
I might not end up in heaven
and God is going to punish me.
And I know it's difficult,
but he's just testing my faith and it's
so sad that they're locked into that.
It's so sad that these religions can't
be more flexible and more progressive.
I wouldn't be so anti religion if I saw
more progressive religion out there.
I have friends that are in progressive,
um,
Christian denominations
and I respect that.
I mean I think it's bullshit and I can't
believe they believe what they believe,
but I'm not going to,
you know,
say that they shouldn't.
I think religions are a type of
operating system for a human being.
And I think that a lot of people need
some set of rules and regulations and
something to look forward to
when it all ends and something,
you know,
the idea of the,
the,
the vast just expanse of the universe
and the insignificant aspect of your life
in relationship to everything you see
in relation to everything you see in the
cosmos.
I think that fucks with people's doors.
Of course it does.
And I think that the real problem with,
with religions,
especially like real fundamentalist
religions that are like really strict and
said they,
they,
they stop your thinking and
cornered in this trap and you,
you,
this operating system that
you're operating under has
this very limited range.
And if it doesn't fall in
this very limited range,
you really can't,
rationally,
you can't accept it.
Those boundaries at all.
And everybody else's outside looking in,
going like,
come out here with us.
Like,
so you don't grow air is a
little cleaner and it is.
Yeah,
but there's aspects of religion
and there's aspects of worship.
Even there's aspects of just worshiping
the and having an appreciation for life
itself and then the,
the incredible wonder of,
of this existence and that
alone should be worshiped.
Even if you call it,
you want to call it God,
you want to call love,
you want to call it appreciation,
call it something.
But the,
the,
the wrong aspects of it,
they're almost like they're something
that inhibits you from getting the best
out of life.
The wrong aspects keep,
it's almost like it has
all this love to it.
Treat your brother as if it's you and
live your life and harmony and do good and
to others.
And you know,
use these laws because they're
designed to make harmony amongst men.
But then the crazy shit like the,
that we,
at some point in time someone
has to rewrite everything
they do and we have some group
roll out all this stuff and say,
these are all just crazy stories,
but this is what we've learned about life.
This is what we've learned in
add science to the equation.
This is what we actually know
about the nature of reality.
Here's some confusing aspects of it.
Here's some things that we're
working on trying to find answers to,
but this is what we actually know our way.
Exactly.
It doesn't preclude the idea of worship.
No.
And you know what?
I don't think that a science and
religion are fundamentally incompatible.
I do think that science and fundamentalism
are anytime that you get to the
fundamentals of any sort of,
uh,
religious mindset,
yes.
That is incompatible with
really strict ideologies.
Anytime it's very dangerous,
even patriotism,
it's very,
very dangerous.
I personally am an atheist.
I personally chose to kind of throw
the baby out with the bathwater on that
because I don't see anything redeeming
in religion that I can't find outside of
religion.
So I don't believe in
anything supernatural.
I don't believe in God.
I don't believe in ghosts.
And Yeah.
Have you watched [inaudible] watch?
Um,
uh,
no.
I have no edge.
It goes tending states.
They claim to have serious evidence.
I'm sure.
James.
Hey,
how dare you got one of
those guys on the show.
Yeah.
Watch out.
Do you notice,
I,
I've noticed that you've had my friend
Jason Silva on the show before and Jason
has this.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And he has a gift for
that kind of spiritual,
almost a warship like wonder of
the natural world of the cosmos.
That is not a religious thing at all,
but it gives you that feeling
that you get from religion.
I actually have a quote on my
tattooed on my ribs down my left side.
That's a quote from Carl Sagan that
says we are away for the cosmos to know
itself.
And it's really powerful to me because
it almost gives me that feedback that a
lot of people get from religion,
but I don't need to get it from religion.
I get it from kind of the
wonder of the universe.
So if you really think about what he's
saying is that the universe is not
conscious and there is no great
conscious organizer out there,
so the universe can't really reflect
on itself because it can't think,
but we as human beings are
made of the stuff of stars.
All of the molecules in our bodies are
traceable to molecular phenomena that was
exploded in the furnace of a star.
So because we are made of the stuff of
stars and because our molecules organized
in such a way to make us higher
thinking cognitive beings and we can to
contemplate our place in the
vast expanses of the universe,
we are away for the universe to know
itself for the cosmos to know it.
Carl Sagan was high as he probably was too
love that you used to love to smoke
pot and just stare at the stars.
He probably had to,
and that's the thing.
He was a a working scientist who made so
many discoveries and who contributed so
much to man's understanding of science.
He was using a drug that wasn't,
it wasn't like he was on acid and
claiming have all of these huge expanded
consciousness experiences.
He was using a drug that
hardly fucks you up.
Like to be honest,
it,
it hardly,
it alters your consciousness so slightly
that he could still work and he could
still make these incredible discoveries,
but he could also find the emotional
valance and like the poetry in the cosmos
and then,
and then tell it to us in such a way
that I think that he inspired an entire
generation of thinkers to grow up to
become scientists or at least to be
scientifically literate and appreciate,
um,
what,
what nature can tell us.
And he was very open about his
appreciation for cannabis and that whole,
uh,
that,
that whole quest for information.
Yeah.
He was a fascinating,
fascinating guys.
I love the fact that it was a pot head.
Yeah.
You were just talking about getting
high and watching Cosmos right before we
started recording.
And Are you excited about the new cosmos
that I'm Seth macfarlane is producing
with Carl Sagan widow Andrew Yun and
they are going to be producing a new
version for Fox hosted
by Neil degrasse Tyson.
Be Awesome.
I know,
I know.
So exciting.
Yeah,
those are some of my most
humble moments ever is.
Um,
I,
I got ahold of,
I don't remember which,
which series it was,
but it was this a 14 DVD series on the
universe and it was one after another,
just mind blowing and credible thing.
I had just gotten this up
projection thing and my house.
So it was like the sound was cool.
The image was crazy.
And for fucking days I
never left that room.
I was just watching these fucking
terrifying documentaries on Supernova.
The possibility of a hyper Nova exploding
near us would just eliminate life on
earth instantaneously.
And the fact they found out that going
on every day all over the universe,
they first thought there
was like an alien war.
The first thought that there was
a fucking alien war out in space.
They were detecting all these explosions
and they thought that like Martians
were shooting at me.
Yeah,
well,
you know,
you got,
you got to explore all
options as scientists.
And this is something that
I do everyday in my job.
It's mind blowing.
Like just,
just yesterday I did a
Skype interview with um,
with a scientist in Washington who wrote
this paper basically that show some
evidence.
They're not claiming that we are,
but they're saying it's not completely
crazy to assume that we might be a
simulation.
Yes.
Yeah.
We've talked about that like a hundred
times and there's legitimate evidence
there that if we can simulate
the fundamental workings
of our own universe right
now,
we can only do it on a femto meter scale.
So we can basically simulate the
inner workings inside of a nucleus.
We can't go any bigger,
but if we can simulate that and
eventually we get to a point where we can
simulate more and more and
more of kind of living,
breathing quantum space.
Who's to say that we
ourselves aren't a simulation.
I just told Joe the other day how I've
been living my life as if we are a
simulation
and if you look at it that way,
it really freaks you out.
And I have this new thing where every
time I talked about the simulation,
I see an Asian come
come around the corner.
So good.
The body guards of the simulation,
trust me,
think of it that way.
Like it will freak you out.
One of those jacks in your pocket.
All of them.
No.
I'm like,
no.
We've been talking about it
for several years now for whatever reason,
but live.
But now start living it though.
Like live your life
like it just for a week.
Everything is assimilation.
That's the,
that's what I am.
I exist.
How do you even live your life that way
freaks you out because then all of a
sudden it's like an addict
lived his life story in a story,
in a story situation.
Like he's done a game of final fantasy.
Okay.
That,
that,
that's what he's doing.
I just remember him bublé Kersey again.
Oh Blake curse the Lakers.
That never worked.
How it worked.
Joe didn't work,
you were just dried.
But those Twitter people who
tried to Bublé it lay denial,
that shit doesn't work.
Uh,
I never,
I never heard.
I'm Todd have to listen on the tosh show
the other day you were on that you're
on Tosh.
Dot.
Online was talking about to play,
not it should.
Anybody else wanted to watch me?
Does that mean Michael [inaudible] he's
going to pop up no life all the time.
No,
no.
First of all,
the curse is this.
Fuck.
We'll talk about Michael.
Bill Blake for the next four days
asking me if I'd been bublé cars.
Didn't know.
Amanda,
your,
Your Games,
you've play Chris.
Awesome dear.
For the next 30 days,
you're going to be laid out
of your mind because I get,
do I get to leave here?
Right?
And then I never have to see.
I know
on Twitter you got to do us bublé updates,
but I bet you'll be blue blade out.
Frothy bublé all over.
Yeah.
Is He's being an asshole right now.
He's sick.
And those people on,
you know it is Christmas time
and he does have a new album out,
which means I'm going to start fucking
hearing those songs everywhere I go.
I've never heard a single Michael Booboo.
So you have,
you just don't know.
I don't have that gene.
Everything's in the background
until your attention is drawn to it.
And then that's all you'll see in here.
I'm missing that part in the brain.
The simulation product,
the brain is replaced with hate.
No hate for what?
For whatever.
For whatever fucking something bad.
Anything bad.
I don't,
I can't listen to it.
It doesn't work.
It's like a dog whistle
and then I don't hear it.
And the acid bird that you hear
chirping in the morning at 5:00 AM,
those are software updates to the,
to the whole simulation.
This is yours.
So Malaysia,
fuck your simulation to hear that.
Way Different than ours.
Hmm.
But this,
what's fascinating about the simulation
theory is these guys that are talking
about that self correcting computer code
that they've found in the computations
of string theory.
Okay.
It's a,
it's a,
it's discovered in 1940 by this
guy named Claude Claude Shannon,
and they've discovered these
exact same self correct.
And Computer Code in bedded in
the equations of string theory.
I don't understand that.
I don't really either,
to be honest.
I just,
I just interviewed a
string who was in town from
the University of Paris.
I interviewed him on Monday and just kind
of tried to get a good primer on what
string theory is,
what it sets out to do.
And I'm going to be doing
writing a video on that soon.
So,
so hopefully I'll be able to kind of
offer a good fundamental primer on string
theory to my,
to my viewers.
But I don't really understand this thing
with the code because the string theory
is right.
Their own mathematics.
I mean,
that's,
that's what a lot of this
kind of theoretical cosmology,
this quantum level cosmology is about.
A lot of times these aren't things
that are really experimentally testable
there.
Things where,
um,
these physicists are trying to map
out or trying to understand the basic
particles,
the basic waves,
um,
that,
that make up the universe and how do
they interact with each other using the
strong force,
the weak force.
Um,
how does gravity come into play with this,
which is a huge problem for them right
now so that they can get this unified
theory.
Most of it right now is just math.
Like to be honest,
it's,
it's all,
whether or not the math works
in these different scenarios,
but they're writing the math,
you know,
they're,
they're trying to learn about these
things and they're trying to document them
and then figure out how
to make the math work.
Once they do that,
the difficulty comes in experimenting
with them because these are such small
particles that occur at such high
energies that you can really only get them
like in a,
in a particle accelerator like at cern.
Or You could find them,
you know,
in,
in a black hole for example.
But we can't study a black hole directly.
So in string theory,
this shit is so small that you can't
even get these things out of a particle
accelerator.
So at this point,
the only way that they can study string
theory is by looking at the cosmic
microwave background radiation,
which is the radiation that
was put off from the big bang.
And it's always around us in
the background and they've
been able to kind of map
at signature and they can
look for basically evidence,
much later evidence,
you know,
13 billion years later,
almost 14 billion years later,
evidence of what happened in the big bang
where these tiny particles would have
come from.
That's incredible.
It's crazy.
I mean it's kind of like,
what the fuck did I even just say?
I'm not really sure that I
understand what I just said,
but I muscled through a real mind blower.
There's going to be so many people
pausing and googling during this pocket.
That's not what they're going
to be good when you fuck.
That's hilarious Brian.
And so many good things happened
this weekend.
Science too.
Like I have,
um,
I had this great thing that I,
it's been floating around Facebook,
um,
from I fucking love
sciences Facebook page.
If you don't follow,
I fucking love it.
Do you mind if I ask a
question before you yeah,
sure.
When when these scientists write the code,
like when,
when you see those
documentaries or those shows,
whenever they have guys talking about
string theory and they're sitting there
with a yellow legal pad.
Yeah.
Scribbling furiously.
Yep.
What the fuck are they doing?
Yeah,
it's,
that's,
I don't know what did it,
what are they saying?
So they're looking basically at,
at the math of the,
they're,
they're trying to look at the universe
and they're trying to describe it in the
only language that we
can describe those very,
very small things then,
which is math.
So they're looking at all of these,
basically these forces that help
particle a interact with particle B,
maybe there's like a,
you know,
a glue on in between.
They're trying to look at the
electromagnetic forces between them.
They're trying to see basically all
of the quantum fluctuations of this,
of this soup of particles that make up
all the things that you see right now,
and they could be in any given place.
It's very difficult to know exactly how
fast they're moving or where they are.
So they have to kind
of look at a range of,
of states of these particles and they're
trying to work out all of the math to
be able to get a whole spectrum of how
these particles interact with each other.
And once they have a really
solid understanding of how
these particles interact
with each other,
then we can start to really understand
why an atom looks like an atom and how
that Adam combines with that Adam to
make a molecule of something and then how
all those molecules coming.
We're pretty good at
knowing from the top down.
You know,
we can look at very big things like
universes and subdivide into galaxies and
subdivide into solar systems.
And then we can even look at earth and
look at all of the life that's on earth
within our own bodies.
We can look at our organ systems,
we can look at us at the cellular level,
we can even break down a sale and
look at it at the molecular level.
But once you get smaller than an atom,
things start acting fucking weird.
And there's a whole new set of laws
that governs the quantum world.
Superpositions the freakiest one.
Yeah.
It's like anything about,
you know,
because it's so hard to
measure these things,
it's,
it's really difficult to measure their
speed and their position at the same time
because they're moving and they're
moving really fucking fast and they,
they,
their properties change depending
on what position they're in.
And so once you get down to these really,
really small,
small,
small but very high energy
levels of the world,
then you,
you start to see different
theories that try to describe them.
And string theory is only
one of those theories.
It's actually one of the more kind of,
um,
bizarre theories.
A lot of people aren't
string theorists in,
in theoretical cosmology,
but string theory is one of the most
promising theories that tries to combine
this kind of Newtonian and
an Einsteinian view together.
So this quantum molecular view and also
having a quantum theory of gravity,
which gravity still doesn't really operate
the same way that most people think
that quantum mechanics operates.
So a big problem that quantum physicists
have is trying to figure out how to fit
Newtonian gravity into the equation so
that they can get a grand unified theory
of everything.
Um,
and right now gravity
doesn't really seem to fit.
Now when they measure particles
that are in super position,
meaning they're in motion
and still at the same time,
how,
what the fuck is that?
What does that mean?
I don't
think it necessarily means that they're
in motion and still at the same time,
I think what it means is that
they can only measure them.
It's,
you know,
a lot of times it's one of the,
becomes one of these questions where
like if a tree falls in the forest,
does it still make a sound?
If we as an observer are trying
to understand the molecular world,
the middle,
just by observing it,
by the,
because we're having,
we can't just look at it,
it's too fucking small.
So we have to come up
with all these crazy rigs,
be able to see things and just buy all
of the technology that we need to use to
see it.
We are affecting it.
So it's really impossible to see things
in their native state when they're the
small without actually
affecting those things.
Hm.
And now how does that work?
Because that's the other thing like,
um,
about the,
the idea of the observer
and quantum mechanics is my
friend Jay d shout out to j
d he's a physicist.
He,
uh,
he related to me that the real issue
is in measuring it and that when you
measure it,
that's the observer.
And it's not necessarily that you are
looking at something or that human
intention or visual,
you know,
the,
your,
your visual Cortex,
this is tuned in on something.
Yeah.
It's just the measuring,
the act of measuring itself changes.
Yeah.
Because it's not like we're
not talking about big things.
So like I could look at this
water bottle and I could,
you know,
make judgements about it.
I could hold a ruler up next to
it and make judgements about it.
I,
it's so large that the tools that I use
to measure it don't interact with its
intrinsic properties.
But once you get down
to things that are very,
very small and you could
no longer use a microscope,
for example,
to see it,
and you have to get down to more
creative ways to measure it,
all of a sudden the creative ways that
you measure it actually process it as,
as they measure it.
And so they're,
they're interacting with it and
they're changing its position,
for example.
Or they're changing the way that it acts
because the only way to really see it,
it's to see it downstream
of something else.
When he said that to me,
I actually got upset because there's
been so much malarkey that I've read and
seen online about the idea of the
observer changing the results that I felt
like,
why did everybody have
to turn into Voodoo?
Oh,
I love that you just said that.
I did.
I did an interview with
Brian Greene who's,
you know,
a pretty renowned physicist and I ended
up doing splitting it into two parts.
One was about black holes and one
was about the multiverse theory,
but one segment that we talked about in
between that I couldn't really work into
a story.
It bums me out because it's such
great footage because I asked him,
how do you feel about movies?
Like what the bleep do we know?
How do you feel about it when people try
to take what you understand about the
quantum world and what you understand
about the cosmos and apply it to like Woo
pseudoscience and say,
oh,
but our thoughts are quantum and now
all of a sudden we can use quantum
mechanics to describe how we think and
how our thoughts live outside of our
bodies and all this bullshit.
And I mean he was very explicit that
no person who studies this stuff,
who's dedicated their lives
to understanding this would
ever try to apply it to
a region of understanding where
the math doesn't make sense.
And so all of the people who are
trying to shill quantum mechanics as an
explanation for thought or behavior
or love or any of these woo things,
none of them are fucking physicists.
That should probably tell us something.
The whole thing was that ramp,
the lady who's a she channels.
Yeah.
All right there.
It's not even telling
what the fuck is going on.
They're just having her talk.
But they're not telling you,
oh no,
no,
no.
She's channeling.
She's channeling some fucking alien.
So many of the people in that
movie were misrepresented.
I mean,
so many people where they would take
like three hours of footage from an
interview and then cut it up in such
a way that it Kinda sorta sounds like
they're making their point.
I did an episode of Larry King.
It was one of the first things I
ever did when I started doing science
communication and being more on air
when I was getting out of the university
system and doing what I do now.
And the episode was
all about neuroscience.
And one of the things that I said on it
was some people would say that the mind
is an entity outside
of the brain that can,
you know,
um,
put forces on the brain.
But we know as modern neuroscientists
that mind and brain are the same thing.
They're just two sides of the same coin.
And how did they run the Promo for that?
The mind is an entity outside
of the brain that can affect,
you know,
they just completely
took it out of context.
They went,
whew.
I mean luckily inside of the episode
they showed it in full so they could see
what I was saying.
But how easy is it?
And as scientist,
you can't be worrying about that when
you're trying to explain something.
You just want to explain it and
hope that they don't bastardize it.
The problem is the people who are
making these things have an agenda
under the,
um,
the idea of consciousness or thought
being outside of the brain is a very
fascinating idea.
The idea that the brain is actually
just an antenna that tunes it all in.
And that's why when different
areas of it get damaged,
that's areas that are designed
to tune in to whatever,
whatever is out there.
The idea of the Akashic records and the
idea that like knowledge and so much of
what makes us human beings is actually
like virtually retrievable from the air.
Well,
I think that there's a way to look
at that without being woo woo,
like I don't think it's
physically in the air,
but there there is obviously this
idea that thoughts and ideas,
once we put them into language,
once we write them down on paper,
they do exist outside of us at this point.
Somebody else can appreciate them
and they can live well past us,
but I still think that all of
that knowledge was conceptualized,
synthesized,
remembered,
retrieved,
whatever by a physical organ,
which is our brain and that thought
is fundamentally a function of brain
activity.
Like I'm,
I'm a really hardcore materialist when
when it comes to that kind of stuff.
What is consciousness though?
That's what's really fascinating.
It's like what the fuck is that
Beautiful Oregon tuning in?
You know what is,
when you're,
when you're at your hype level,
you're,
you're locked on to some crazy explanation
and you're very passionate and like
what is that that's
coming through that brain?
I don't,
it's not coming through the brain.
It's being created by the brain.
And to me it's,
it's the same thing as saying like,
what is it when an athlete is that peak
performance and their heart is working
the best way that it can possibly work.
The problem is the brain is
so much more complicated.
There's so much more metabolism
happening in the brain,
and there's so many individual neurons
that have so many connections between
them.
And there's so many
different kind of options,
kind of permutations and combinations of
ways that these neurons can communicate
with one another that thought that
consciousness somehow arises from all of
those connections.
But that's the,
that's the holy grail of neuroscience.
And this is what I love.
This is my background is neuroscience.
And so when I do,
um,
all of my science reporting and
all of my science commenting,
all the space stuff and
all of the physics stuff,
I'm not as good at,
you know,
I have to learn it as I go.
Um,
which kind of I think helps me
when I communicate it because I,
I,
I get where people are coming
from when they're like,
I don't fucking understand this at all.
The neuroscience stuff is
like my bread and butter.
That's what I love.
And that is the holy grail of neuroscience
pro type dudes.
Talk about consciousness.
My eyes rolling like Deepak Chopra.
I just,
it's really hard for me to not
just discount everything he says.
Really.
I reason,
I mean,
I know that there's true therapist.
He is,
he's a whoop peddler
Chopra,
um,
uh,
Eckhart.
Totally.
Tony Robbins is that his name is,
loves a cart.
Totally.
He's totally is probably the
least hook story of all of them,
but he's still
well,
what,
what do you think is huck story about
providing motivation to people and giving
people sort of a,
a framework to work on as far as,
uh,
living in the now and
taking charge of their life,
especially if it's something
that someone like Eckhart Tolle,
a,
uh,
had personal
just so compare somebody like a cart.
Totally goofy.
Robin's compare and Eckhart totally.
Or an Anthony Robbins to,
for example,
somebody like,
um,
oh,
what's his name?
I was able to,
God,
no,
I was able to interview uh,
this,
this really interesting guy who has a phd
in molecular genetics and then move to
the Himalayas to become a Buddhist monk.
Um,
his name is Matthieu Ricard and he's,
he's a French Buddhist monk and he talks
about mindfulness meditation and he
talks about the neuroscience of the
things that the Tibetans are doing right
now,
but he's not trying to
make money off of it.
And I think that is a fundamental
kind of red flag for me.
I'm not saying just because
somebody is trying to make money,
they are selling snake oil.
Right?
First of all,
what's the motivation that,
that that has to be the first red flag.
And then you go into,
what is it that they're
saying if they're talking,
if they're trying to use science and
they're trying to kind of go in and pick
and choose the science that tells the
story the right way and then they're
making these really broad
a leaps from that science.
It makes me nervous.
So it's,
it's one thing if you've got like a
motivational speaker who's just like,
I know this about the world and
I'm not basing it on anything,
but if you like me,
come follow me.
And it's like,
yeah,
that's fine.
I mean,
what is that?
That's like culty behavior,
but that's fine.
But when people pick and choose how they
want to use science and how they want
to bastardize science to meet their needs,
it makes me nervous.
I did a piece recently
about the power of thinking.
Um,
I've also done a piece about the
power of prayer and I went through the
literature and I tried to find examples
where positive thinking actually helped
people.
And there's just no good evidence that
thinking positively is going to actually
bring goodwill to your life.
Like,
like the secret,
you know this like,
well if I just want it bad enough,
I'm going to make a bunch of money.
It's like,
no,
if you want it bad enough,
you're going to have
to fucking work for it.
And then it's gonna come to you.
And actually they find that the power of
positive thinking can actually be kind
of detrimental to cancer patients because
it causes a whole extra layer of guilt
to the process of dying,
you know,
caused us to yourself.
Exactly.
Because you didn't,
you didn't think positively enough,
you didn't will yourself out of this.
And there's a whole culture around that
in America where we kind of blame the
victims and where we
call cancer survivors,
survivors,
and we call cancer victims victims,
you know,
and,
and it's like,
and you're not doing so well.
Nobody says it directly to
somebody who was dying of cancer.
Well you didn't will yourself out of it,
but they feel that because they say it
indirectly to the people who are coming
out of it.
Oh,
it was all that nice prayer and all those
positive thoughts and all those Oprah
magazines you read.
You know,
and it's like,
ah,
I don't know.
I think that's a bad precedent to set.
It's also shitty science
because if you're,
you know,
you're only looking at the
group that was successful.
Exactly.
What about all the people that died?
And that's the thing.
I tried to look at a lot of those
studies and I tried to compare,
you know,
and,
and I found enough stuff out there that
kind of shows that the power of positive
thinking is not a real thing.
Also,
that shows that prayer
is not a real thing.
Disagree.
That the power of positive
thinking is not a real thing.
I think it's a good way to operate and
live your life in a happy manner and will
probably lend you to
being more successful.
You'll have less hurdles.
It's like,
it's like talking about Karma,
you know,
like in some sense Karma is totally real
because if you're a fucking nice person
and you're just,
you,
you do goodwill all of the time,
sometimes shitty things
are going to happen to you.
But most people are going
to be nice to you too.
If you put bad Karma out there.
To me what that really means is if you're
just a fucking asshole all the time,
people are going to be
an asshole back to you.
Like that's obvious.
But I don't believe that Karma is some
sort of cosmic force that says you,
you store up goodwill with the universe
and the universe pays you back in some
way
field that it is because that's
how it applies to a socially.
Yes.
So we sort of like the,
I've always felt that the idea of the
birth and the death of the universe was a
weird concept and that maybe were wrapped
around that because of the idea of our
own biological limitations.
I've always thought,
yeah,
like time is so interesting
because time is,
is is a real thing.
Flexible though.
It's flexible.
Yes.
But it is also a real thing,
but we perceive it to be something that's
in some ways quite different than what
time actually.
Yeah.
Well when you start getting into crazy
shit like a spaceship that goes faster
than the speed of light and then it
comes back to Earth in 20 years and 500
years have passed or whatever the fuck.
Yeah.
Or it would be earlier,
earlier,
come back earlier than when you left.
If it's faster than this.
So you'd have to,
yeah,
you have to go really much
faster that you do that.
You could see
they say that if you are many,
like if you're a million light years away
from earth and you could look back and
yeah,
yeah.
Like if you left on a spaceship and you
were going faster to the speed of light
and you got a crazy ass,
tell us,
go on Mars and then you turned
your telescope towards earth,
you would see yourself landing.
What the fuck?
That's why Einstein says you can't
go faster than the speed of light.
What if you can you
just fuck everything up?
Well,
that's what everybody,
I mean that's,
that's the fascinating
thing about thinking about.
Do you ever wonder,
like when you see things
like Fukushima and you see,
you know,
nuclear disasters and the,
all the potential nuclear disasters,
a different places that we
have all over the [inaudible],
just California that are on
fault lines or near fault lines.
Does that,
does that freak you out?
Do you wonder about like the
idea behind nuclear power?
I mean,
sure,
it's been very beneficial to societies,
but if you have to look
at whatever it's been,
how many 60 years of implementation and
there's three parts of the world that
are broken now.
Yeah.
You know,
you know what's funny is I think
that there's this huge disconnect in,
in,
in public opinion between,
again,
science and implementation.
And I always,
I shouldn't say always,
but I'm often an advocate of doing
science for the sake of science.
I'm often an advocate of just
trying to learn as much as we can.
I think that once these
things get implemented as
technologies and as sources of
engineering,
that's why we have a government and
government is supposed to be better at
making sure that all of these
things are checked and balanced,
you know,
and that we should have
good protocols when,
when the,
when the earthquake struck in Italy and
all of those seismologists who basically
said,
I'm not sure that this is going to happen,
I wouldn't worry about it too much.
And then so many people died.
Um,
everybody blamed the scientists,
the charged with manslaughter,
they charge him with manslaughter,
they blamed the scientist.
Nobody blamed any of the civil engineers,
any of the people overseeing whether
or not the buildings were up to code,
whether or not the city was built in
such a way that it could withstand an
earthquake.
And it's,
it's absolutely insane to me that the
people who were tasked with just trying to
understand whether or not,
and we can't predict
earthquakes by the way we can,
and you're talking about Italy and that's
where the Vatican is and that's the
biggest center of nonsense in
the known universe for damn sure.
It's the craziest fucking setup ever.
And that's an Italy kind of fuckery
they deal with on a regular basis.
Yeah.
But we see this,
I mean that's the thing.
We don't have a global government.
You know,
we have a chai,
maybe the church wanted them to get
charged with manslaughter so they can move
into a stronger position.
Maybe they,
maybe they tried to like push that.
I just think people scapegoat.
People want somebody to blame,
you know what I mean?
And the pencil pushers with their
glasses sitting behind their desk.
We're an easy target and it's really
fucking sad because it sets a terrible
precedent and it makes it
so that seismologist the
world over are going to be
nervous to,
to have any sort of report.
If a government official comes
and says,
look at all of this data,
do you think that there's a risk that
something like this could happen to us
soon?
They're going to go,
I don't want to fucking say anything.
I'm just gonna keep my mouth
shut because I don't want to get
trouble.
Well,
not only that,
but how,
how could they,
the people that are in
charge of the legal system,
how could they prosecute him when everyone
knows that it's impossible to predict
earthquakes?
Fucking no butts.
How could someone make that decision
if there's no evidence they did?
That's so crazy.
I mean,
hopefully they overturn it
because people like what the fuck?
Like they wanted this to happen.
They caused the earthquake.
Like what the fuck are you saying?
It doesn't make it.
It makes no sense.
Absolutely no sense.
But at least that's Italy.
We can get our stupid fucks.
That's where my grandparents
fled the Italians,
a little bit of Irish and
they fled to half Italian,
half Puerto Rican.
Do you know if I recombination
for a neuroscientist,
young lady
by a space ship?
I mean it's,
I don't know as much about it exactly,
but I was going to say there's this,
there's this,
I'm kind of meme that's going
around on Facebook right now,
and I shared it on my page and it just
says this week in science 12 to 2012 and
it's like Nasa Messenger spacecraft
discovered evidence of ice and organic
compounds on mercury.
DNA was photographed for the first time.
A quasar was observed that puts out a
hundred times more energy than our entire
galaxy.
I know a black hole with a massive 17
or 17 billion suns was observed and
another of Saturn's moons was found
to have a pac man like heat signature.
And that's not to mention the
findings of the curiosity rover.
So I mean,
this is this just this week,
just this week.
This is why my job is so fucking cool.
That's pretty cool.
Yeah.
This is the best time ever to have it too.
I feel like,
I feel like that's the case too.
I mean there's,
we've never been in an
intellectual climate that's
so detrimental to scientific
thinking,
but we've also never been
in a technological climate
that's so permissive of
scientific progress.
Great.
I think there's always
going to be loud people,
but I think generally across the board,
people are much more open
minded to science and
understanding of the reality of
the universe than they
ever have been before.
Then they have,
I guess I should say within,
I feel like within this century,
within the last century,
I should say we're in a very anti science
figured out in the Reagan
administration era.
They figured out how to
make it a lot of noise.
One of the good ways to do it is like
you can get elected if you get the
Christian,
it's on your side and,
and that's just gained momentum and
that's really sad because I would love to
see us go back to the 60
I mean in a sense to the,
to the way that science was perceived
in the 60s to the excitement about NASA,
to the excitement about the space race.
It's science.
Look,
if,
if we are the universe
trying to understand itself,
science truly is the
religion because that,
that's the religion of trying
to understand everything
truthfully and cutting
out all the fuckery,
cutting out all the nonsense.
The problem is that
the word religion,
just like the word God,
I feel like have a connotation.
Yeah.
They're tainted.
Just like,
just like the swastika,
you know,
it's tainted.
And so when you go back to kindle it will,
it was like,
it's like the oldest symbol on earth,
you know?
And if you go to like these
different old parts of Asia,
it's everywhere.
But now it's tainted.
Yeah.
There's a place near,
um,
I think it's in,
somewhere in the valley and it's this
really ancient house that was built by
these people from India and
the swastikas all over there.
Yeah.
So they have to explain,
it's like a plaque
explaining the swastika.
Exactly.
But that's what happens.
You know,
you,
you link it with something
fucking horrible.
Like religion,
in my view,
has been so fucking horrible for so long.
It's tainted and the idea
of God immediately draws
up in a Christian ideal of
like a white bearded guy living in like
on a cloud or some shit that's going to
cast judgment on you.
So when people talk about,
yeah,
but I see God more as,
I'm like call it fucking
something different because
it confuses me every time
you use the word God maybe.
Yeah.
Maybe.
Or how,
what we just don't use the word God.
We just talk about
science as being mobile.
Yeah.
Call it [inaudible] figure out.
But science is just incredible.
It's incredible.
And it's all inspiring and learning about
our own existence is why we are so you
feel like conscious,
this is really just a byproduct of all
these different synapses firing and all
of these different cells.
Charging and igniting and filling with
thought and intention and instincts and
jeans.
I do.
I don't know if I feel like
the word byproduct maybe.
Awesome.
I should of said product of or
you know,
the uh,
the end result of the,
the moving force behind
the biological unit.
Yes.
I think that mind and brain
are two sides of the same coin.
Mind thought consciousness arises as a,
as a physical Manistee
manifestation of brain activity.
So the brain does what it does
and through it we have thought.
So you think that the,
the concept of the soul and the idea
that there's some conscious being trapped
in your,
your,
your meat vehicle?
Yeah.
I don't believe it.
Don't believe in that.
Believe in the ghost in the shell.
I don't think anything
persist once we die.
For example,
when we died,
we were off.
That's it.
That's a wrap.
Yeah.
Do you think there's a
universal consciousness?
No.
Just a universal,
I mean
I think there are laws,
there are fundamental laws of
nature that cannot be broken,
but I don't think that
they have meaning in them.
I think they just are.
You don't think that
there's some sort of a,
a pattern,
a very clear pattern of,
uh,
a constant that like,
if you look at like from
the big bang to now,
especially if you look
at just our culture,
the constant innovation and
progress and moving forward.
The,
just from looking at planets that go from
single celled organisms like you know,
we did and to,
to what we have now with the Internet
and having this kind of the ability to
broadcast something
like this on a podcast,
the isn't that the,
that there's some sort
of a pattern that it's,
it's moving in a very specific direction
and unless there's some horrible
disaster that stops this course,
we're going to continue to move
in a more and more advanced.
I definitely think that there,
we're seeing exponential growth in,
in technological advances,
but I don't think that that means
that there's somebody driving that,
right?
No,
no.
Not that someone's driving it,
but there is absolutely a,
a pattern and it almost
seems insurmountable.
It's like it's not going
to stop the idea of it.
The only thing that's
going to stop technological
innovation and progress is you
got to shut all the power off.
Yeah.
Forever.
I mean,
I personally think that,
you know,
people talk about the kind of Kurzweilian
singularity and when man and machine
combine and then we can live forever
because we can download our consciousness
or whatever.
I personally don't think that Ray Kurzweil
has the best grasp of how the brain
works,
how the human brain works.
And so I'm not sure that I really
buy into what he's selling,
but eventually if we got to a point where
AI was kind of sophisticated enough,
I think that I worry,
you know,
when we talk about what is
going to be the end for humans,
I personally think that we're
going to fuck ourselves.
That we're just too much of a war.
Like you know,
but we're not because you
hold short term intruders.
I won't,
but I don't have babies so I'm
not passing these genes on.
At least not yet.
You go pass him jeans,
go do some breeding.
Um,
yeah,
that's the,
the question of whether or not we're
going to fuck it up is certainly a valid
one.
You know,
we,
a lot of us have bombs.
We've done a lot of nuclear explosions.
Yes.
Well we may have colonize something.
I mean,
I just,
I just did a chat yesterday
with two guys from Mars.
One,
which is this Dutch company that plans
to colonize Mars in 2023 and that's an 11
years it should have happened.
Right.
That's great.
Can I get some money and then
they're going to go all John McAfee?
Well,
they,
what was that Brian?
I know there's crazy
people out in the back.
Wow.
Is that that if someone opened the back,
we should hadn't been
mentioned the simulation.
I know they're coming to shut us down.
Um,
no.
I think that they really want to do it.
It's a nonprofit organization and you
know what their plan is to get funding.
They want to make this mission
of the first colonists to Mars.
I don't know if there'll be successful,
but I do think that they're
going to try to do it.
Definitely kill a few people in space.
They plan on the plan on making
this the most insane reality.
Oh Jesus.
That's where I just checked out.
If they were real scientists,
would they do that?
Would they turn into a reality?
The only way they can get money for it.
Wow.
I'm on board on the booboo.
And I asked them,
I was like,
what are you going to do
if something goes horribly,
horribly wrong?
This is an extremely risky endeavor.
Right.
You know,
and they were saying at this point,
we'll have been training
these people for 10 years.
They're going to be our friends.
These people that we're
sending up to colonize Mars,
they can't bring them back.
By the way,
these people are going to go to Mars
and they're going to live out their days
off.
Oh yeah.
And
what happens when something
goes horribly wrong?
And they're like,
that's when we have to shut off the,
because
you can't,
you can't.
Televise a friend of yours
dying on that.
Alaska shows the,
uh,
one of the guys died.
I mean,
they didn't actually show him dying,
but I mean,
he died while they were filming the show.
I mean,
they,
they have had deaths on
reality shows before.
All they'd have to do is
just figure out a way to,
you know,
not to in the camera in and tell them
that there was some sort of a chemical x
fixation issue or whatever the fuck it
is that kills you when you're on a planet
that doesn't have air on.
If you even make it to the
planet and crazy bitch.
Like what the fuck?
It's crazy.
And so their idea is that every 10
years they want to send for more people.
So it's like four people and four people,
four people and they're
going to have to be a doctor,
an engineer,
whatever.
Because they're going to have to be
able to grow the colony out there and
eventually start terraforming.
I mean hopefully we'll get to a point
where we could blast something off of Mars
eventually to come back to earth.
But until then they're going to
have to just make supply runs.
They're going to have to just send
things to Mars and we know it takes like,
what,
nine months to get there.
You got to wait nine months,
nine months and hope that it doesn't get,
you know,
blow up on the way there.
I mean it's absolutely insane.
I can't really wrap my head around it.
I know they're going to try it.
I don't know if there'll be successful,
but the whole time I was doing this,
this segment on huffpost live yesterday,
I just kept stopping and being like,
fucking seriously talking
about this right now.
Like what a time to be
alive that you're having.
I mean,
I was having a serious
conversation with these.
So when you send these colonists to Mars,
what kind of tools will they need?
I mean,
it was absolutely blowing my mind,
planning on trying to
terraform that eventually,
but they need to have a
lot of people their first,
so they get a lot of people there and
then they have some sort of a power source
and then they start,
I guess the or the Ema
and we've got the sun,
you know,
so they just come up
there with no atmosphere.
Right.
So it's super thin atmosphere.
They did find out that there is,
um,
it,
it will,
it's cold.
It's very cold on Mars during the
days I should say the Saul's so Mars,
it has a different day than earth,
so they call themselves during the salts.
They have um,
uh,
it actually does get pretty
warm like in the forties.
Um,
but at night it's like,
it's too cold to survive.
It's so,
so cold and there's no
liquid water on Mars,
so they'd have to figure that out too.
Fuck that.
Don't go to Mars.
People stop trying to prove a point.
You crazy ass hole.
I kept wanting to say to them like,
you're so fucking crazy.
But then I want it to be like,
it's because of crazy
motherfuckers like you.
That stuff happens.
It's because somebody was like,
let's go to the fucking
moon and everybody's and
probably somebody who don't
fucking go to the moon.
You're going to die.
You idiot.
But they figured out how to go.
How cool would it be if we keep on frog
hopping from like Mars to another plant,
to another planet and
then it just gets code.
There's no like it wasn't programmed
that would actually go that far
out.
[inaudible] they haven't
figured out that part.
Yeah.
Whoa.
Do you buy into like the
simulation theory talked?
I mean do you ever
entertain it whatsoever?
You know I was,
I was talking to the scientists that
I interviewed about it and I was like,
first of all,
do you really believe this?
And he was like,
I'm a scientist,
I'm not a philosopher.
I just tried to look at the math.
And so I stopped him and said,
you know,
you eventually scientific conferences
and you also talk about it to the media
and eventually you use the word they,
you know,
if times,
so maybe they are right.
And I was like,
who is this day I want to talk
to you about where you know,
and he had the most brilliant answer
cause I thought he was going to go the God
route and I was like no fuck.
But he had the most brilliant answer.
He said once,
he said we are finally at a point in
our evolution that we are sophisticated
enough to write these
fundamental bits of code.
Cause that's the whole point of this.
Who's to say that we aren't a simulation?
If we can write our own simulation of
a very small portion of the universe,
well,
if we're sophisticated
enough to write our own,
a very small simulation,
who's to say that hundreds of thousand
years in the future we couldn't simulate
the whole universe.
So maybe the day is just us simulating
the past to figure out where they came
from.
Well,
I said that my take on the simulation
theory was that we live in the future like
those gray aliens.
That's us.
That's what we really look like.
We have no sexual organs because we
figured out a way to reproduce through
genetics,
genetic mutations or
you don't exist anymore.
Giant eyeballs with builtin sunglasses
because we completely fucked up the
environment,
need sunglasses.
Everywhere we go,
we don't have a mouth anymore because
we talk with our brain and we're bored.
We fucked up.
We engineered all the fun out of
reality to see where we came from.
We went back to the roaring
twenties technological age,
the time where people were still sending
Dick pics to people on Facebook and it
nutty shit was still going to,
no one knew the rules.
This is the wild west of the,
of the Internet age.
We live in a future that's just not fun.
We've engineered all the good times out
of it and what we've decided to do is go
back to the roaring twenties of what it
all was fucking wild and crazy and you
could get bit torrent still
when we were watching rejected.
You guys remember rejected.
Ooh,
Ooh.
Talking about this for so long and I'll,
although I am joking
around when I say that,
I don't really believe that we are the
aliens cause I don't really believe any
of it.
I don't really know.
Yeah.
I mean it's hard to believe
something without good evidence,
but it's interesting to philosophize
and it's also interesting that that,
that sort of archetype,
that alien,
that's sort of a really
stereotypical alien.
It repeats itself over and over
and over again with the big head,
the little skinny body.
Yeah.
What does religion,
if you look at all of the lore built
into religion across so many cultures,
the Virgin Birth Story,
the resurrection story,
so many religions use that.
But as far as like the way
a human looks from the wig,
gorilla looks,
you know,
you look at other primates and
you know the way monkeys look,
the way,
you know,
we have to figure,
we all came from some very
similar source at one long,
long distant part in the past.
If you look at a gorilla and then you
look at a person and then you look at an
alien,
it's like,
yeah,
that's,
that's how it goes.
Yeah.
I mean it doesn't seem that far fetched.
Like why would we develop like scales
or like have a shark fin or some shit
that's like not our evolutionary lineage.
By the way.
They're developing all
these artificial skins.
Some of them with spider silk,
did they believe it's
going to be bulletproof?
They're talking about engineering
human skin with fucking spider silk.
So you become like some
bulletproof person.
Do you know?
Fuck it.
That's sad when people
don't tear open anymore.
Like you can't like,
like that's what it's going to be.
That's what it's going to take for
people to stop fucking like having gun
violence.
But what if we all become bulletproof?
Yeah.
But what if you couldn't feel shit when
you like we're touching each other well
and you have bulletproof coffee
only shoot for the balls,
everyone to aiming for the deck.
So bulletproof deck
your genitals would be the only
thing that wouldn't be bulletproof.
Right?
Yeah.
I mean,
you know that there are
people who have a genetic um,
deficits where they can't feel pain.
Yeah.
And it's,
and it sounds like a perk,
but it is not,
they usually die because they break bones.
They'll have internal bleed,
they'll get an accident
and they won't know.
Well that's also been the speculation
for people that do a lot of uh,
a body like,
like piercing their balls
and craziness and yeah.
Things under their skin.
They say that they're having,
that they have a hard time feeling things
and like real severe pain is like the
only thing that lets them
know that they're alive.
Disconnect between that mechanism.
They say that a lot of people who,
uh,
choose to have a get
let animals fuck them.
Or like a lot of those
guys have the same thing.
This is not true.
Brian,
his peers probably brought
it back to the dolphin.
Fucking Mr. Haney.
Um,
Mr hands is a of a very famous Internet
video of a guy who got killed while
horse was having sex with them.
And there the,
they actually made a documentary
about the whole situation.
It's called zoo because the,
the realized there was a whole group of
people that lived in Washington state
and we're having sex
with all these animals.
And they had all these video because
it was legal and is that so they move,
they met on the Internet and they moved
to Washington state and they all like,
like went to this farm
and they got together.
All right.
The animals.
Well,
the animals,
just fuck horses.
Horses.
Fuck them.
Fuck this guy and killed on it.
But the horse is still alive.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
It was fine.
He didn't even bleed.
It get
scratched.
But he,
the guy who's getting fucked by the horse
has all these piercings all over his
balls and I was talking to a
doctor about it and it's like it's,
it's there's,
there's very often those really self
destructive people have like an issue like
feeling pain.
Yeah.
I could see that.
Whether it's a psychological
block or an actual physical,
what does that say about
us with all the tattoos?
I don't know.
I just think they look cool.
I think they look cool too.
I like art.
I like art and I don't,
I don't mind having them having
it on my body and people are like,
well then it's forever,
but I don't really think of this molecule
that you have on your arm that's done
a field trip to mean.
I did it.
I did.
I did a piece about the near death
experience questioning whether it was just
because of DMT.
Then also the alien abduction experience.
Yeah.
Variance in the the near death experience.
All of them they believe
may be influenced by DMT.
We know our brain makes it,
we know the lungs producer,
we know it's produced in the liver,
and we also know it's
unbelievably psychoactive
and that just feels like a little bit
more rational and explanation to me.
Certainly for the alien abduction thing.
Yeah,
the alien abduction thing.
What is that?
You Bitch,
you're getting presence
on the air on the podcast.
Oh,
he stopped recording like hours ago,
president.
It took me forever to find that.
It's a,
it's a,
it's a chimpanzee [inaudible] hour.
It comes out and goes.
That might be the cutest thing.
That's awesome man.
I love it too little monkey.
Even though my production company is
called talking Mckee and my tee shirt
company is called higher primate.
I have a,
I have an issue with monkeys.
I don't know what it is.
We have a common ancestor.
I Dunno.
Yeah.
What's the difference?
Monkeys have tails.
Right.
And they're more
conti.
Um,
do you believe that there is an
undiscovered primate living in the Pacific
northwest?
That people believe that?
No.
They know it's bigfoot.
We have to ask everyone
who killed [inaudible].
Okay.
First of all,
do you know?
Says yes.
Jane Goodall.
She's convinced.
Yeah,
she's convinced.
She said that there's far too many
stories that are exactly the same.
The the images throughout time.
This pictograph over a thousand years ago.
She,
she,
she wants to believe,
I believe.
I'll believe it when I see evidence.
They
know that it's a,
they know that a driver can't epiphysis
existed alongside human beings as
recently as 100,000 years ago.
In fact,
there was bones of them.
They would discover it in like one
of those Chinese medicine places.
Gigantic [inaudible].
This is an actual bipedal ape that existed
as recently as a hundred
thousand years ago.
Possibly more recently
lived alongside people.
It was eight feet tall,
huge and Asia and may have came down
the Bering straits along with people.
And the idea is that if
there were intelligent and
they probably are just like,
you know,
if they're by pedal,
they might be the only other,
I mean,
yeah.
Did we fuck them?
Because we fucked me,
Andrew.
I mean there's Neanderthal
DNA in many humans.
Yeah,
but isn't it
whether or not we fucked them and whether
or not we just have their trace DNA in
her,
what would we get it
without fucking right.
I'll,
I'll put that up because I don't
understand that we've talked to that.
Do you think we fucked
them where they fucked up?
They fucked us.
Either one.
Did they fuck the girls or the men?
Fuck this.
I don't know.
We probably double fucked to them because
they are no longer around and we still
are.
Yeah.
We told you're fuck.
There's actually a,
there's a,
I'm going to do a piece on it.
Um,
I just got my kit in the mail.
Nat Geo has this like geno typing or this,
not geno typing,
but this genographic project
where you can do a g a cheek swab,
send them your DNA and they will give
you like the background of your ancestor.
Yeah.
I'm all monkey.
They're gonna find out.
I'm not even a fucking
like monkey throwing,
throwing something like you
have to do a monthly thing.
I was going to do it,
but then I've found like
it was a subscription.
Some kinds of description study.
Yeah.
Here it is.
Study casts,
doubt on human neanderthals.
Interbreeding theory.
Cambridge scientists claim DNA overlap
between the entitles and notice how I
said in the end are tall.
Nanda tall.
Yeah.
Smart person on the podcast.
You uh,
and modern humans is a
remnant of a common name.
Yeah.
It could be that kid.
That could be the case also.
Or are we going to fuck dumb?
Come on.
How do they really know?
For sure we will somebody fucked one.
No doubt if they were alive with this.
It's just whether or not
they ever encountered.
Yeah,
but I don't know.
I mean if people fuck horses.
Yeah.
Where's the mermaids?
Well,
we never fucked.
I don't think we ever fucked anything
that like lived in the water that looked
like a person.
Yeah.
I don't think,
well,
and we wouldn't have
viable offspring anyway.
We couldn't fuck a chimp and make a baby.
Right.
Like it would,
it would spontaneously abort.
But if they're close enough,
like a dog and a wolf can have sex
and they'll have viable offspring.
Well all dogs came from wall.
Exactly.
And so,
so it's fuck,
it's a mind fuck in and
of itself or towels in us.
If we were close enough,
we might have been able
to have viable offspring,
but we don't know.
Oh yeah,
I bet some,
well maybe a few of them,
maybe they're really smart
in the end are talking.
Maybe we did fuck them,
but maybe it is a trace from a common
ancestor and we just walked him for fun.
And that's not how we got their DNA.
Me is first of all how few fossils
there really are as opposed to how many
things that ever lived and when
they find something new like that,
home loaf homofloresiensis stuff though.
The hobbit man from the Ilo Flores,
that makes you wreck really geek out.
Like Holy Shit,
ten thousand thirteen thousand
years ago there was this
monkey man and they just found,
they just found like the biggest dinosaur.
Yeah.
Or not the biggest.
The oldest.
I'm sorry,
the oldest dinosaur.
I wish.
I thought I had it pulled out.
If Monsanto just paid for
all these dinosaur bones,
there was never really dinosaurs and
it's this huge thing just to control the
population.
Bones existed before Monsanto.
You could have Google
saved us so much time.
You mother would've been Santa
was a different thing back then.
Indians.
Funny is that there are creationists
who really think the dinosaur bones were
put into the ground to test our faith.
That's brilliant.
The the,
the,
the ability to control really
fucking dumb people is an art form.
It really is.
If you watch those dudes that are on
the late night TV shows screaming and
hollering and a Hooten about Jesus,
there is an art form to that.
Sam Kinison who was,
in my opinion,
at least at one point,
Tom,
he was the greatest comedian
ever for like a like a year.
I think he's the greatest
community in ever.
That's how I started out as a preacher.
He was a
Pentecostal tongue.
Jesus.
He was,
yeah,
he was.
I'm pretty sure it's Pentecostal.
I think I should look that up
because I'm a big fan of Kennison,
but whatever he was,
he was a reverend and a,
you know that,
that's where he got his
skill from on stage.
That like commanding presence.
That's a very specific
type of performance art.
It's just getting rubes to send you money.
I just found,
I just found this article
about this dinosaur.
It was called Nyasa saurus pairing.
Tony.
Wow.
And it was it,
it was small.
It was the size of a Labrador.
But they say that it came from
about 240 to 245 million years ago,
which would make it one of
the earliest dinosaurs ever.
And it would've been
roaming pangea at the time,
basically when all the continents
were one big supercontinent Uzi,
you know my favorite animal
that nobody knows about?
Terror,
birds,
terror birds like terror or birds.
What's a terror?
Gigantic predatory birds
that roamed North America.
They,
it's reasonable.
I mean,
because birds are dinosaurs.
Like we know that for a fact,
dinosaurs evolved to become birds.
Actually the tattoo on my right arm
right here is a is archaeopteryx
lithographic,
which is basically a Burg dinosaur.
It was a total missing link.
These things are fucking horrifying.
I think birds today
are kind of horrifying.
Have you ever seen the documentary
the BBC did on the Congo and this one
gigantic prehistoric bird,
I think it's called the shoe bill and
it's this crazy ancient dinosaur of a
bird.
It's about five feet tall,
enormous,
huge beak and it's walking in the water.
All creepy.
I'd and fucked up with huge piece.
I mean the biggest like three feet long
and then it plunges in water and kills
this fish and pulls it out.
It's fucking weird is by the way,
that thing would eat a baby.
You left the baby on the
ground with that thing.
That thing would eat the
fuck out of your baby.
Do you know any friends who have
African gray parrots like as pets?
Those things live like 60 years.
We look them in the eye and they look
at you all creepy and you can see the
dinosaur fucking scary birds,
birds,
birds
are our national animal is a
fucking evil cunt of a bird.
Our national animal.
You look at the,
you ever look at an eagle?
Me,
I think I've talked to fucking coachee.
That is the most reptilian bird you could
ever possibly wrap your head around.
All the raptors really are,
I mean scary,
just like the raptors from Jurassic Park,
like that's,
that's really the same kind of thing
you're dealing with and they're smart of
crows.
I Love Crows because people paint
crows out to be really evil.
I did a whole piece on crows.
They're brilliant,
they're clever as fuck,
and they're so,
and they're beautiful.
They might be as smart
as dolphins use tools.
I interviewed this guy
who does crow research.
They did this study where they wore
masks and like just neutral masks,
but they would do,
they would do a helpful condition and
then kind of like a harsh condition.
So the healthful condition,
they would feed the crows and then in the
harsh position they would capture them
and tag them.
And so then when they went
outside wearing the masks,
I think for up to seven years,
maybe 10 years later,
the,
when they saw somebody in a mask
that was in the helpful condition,
the crows would come up and ask for food.
When they saw them in
the harmful position,
they would squawk at them
and like try to attack them.
And it wasn't even the person,
it was just the mask
they remembered faces.
I mean,
it's crazy.
There's a lot of crows where I live.
They like,
there's like a,
what is that a murder of?
Yeah,
a murderer.
That's amazing.
Yeah,
I know.
That's crazy.
They're brilliant.
And they use tools,
right?
And then they snowboard.
There's a video on youtube
of snowboarding crow,
which is like the best thing ever.
It's like it finds a little roof tile
or something carries it to the top of a
roof and Russia slides down.
It doesn't fly away,
decides it was fun and does it again,
like it does it four times in a row.
So it's obviously using this as a tool.
Tend to ski or snowboard.
Yeah,
it's having fun.
It's amazing.
Why are they so smart?
Fuck.
Marry,
kill dolphin,
cro or bublé.
I want to,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna.
I'm gonna kill him.
I'm gonna kill you.
Right?
I'm going to kill the crow.
I'm going to,
I want to fuck.
And Mary,
can I just fuck and Mary bublé.
No,
I don't want to fuck a dolphin.
You Guy.
Well,
you should marry the dolphin and fuck.
Bublé that way of blue bloods,
douchey.
You don't even have to get divorced
because you're married to a dolphin,
right?
Yeah.
It's no big deal.
The Dolphin.
Yeah.
You say,
look,
I would love to marry,
and it's not even cheating
because it's not even a person.
That's how the guys who fuck horses look
at him cheating on my wife because it's
not a real person owning a horse.
Fuck me.
I would kill bublé fuck the
cro and marry the dolphin.
Yeah,
of course.
Thanks.
Thanks for your contribution.
Really,
really super sweet apiece.
Appreciate it.
You're the best.
I wanted to ask you about ambien because
that's one of the stories that's on
your,
uh,
on your website,
right?
Yeah.
That's up posts published on Monday.
Tell what the fuck
is going on with Ambien.
So it's interesting.
You know,
I was talking to Arianna about
kind of like story ideas.
Arianna Huffington,
how cool are you that you
could just say Ariana,
that's like,
that's like saying Elvis would
have to say the last name.
I'm going to Ariana and we
were just coming up with,
we were talking about what kinds of
things people want to hear about,
you know,
what's on a lot of people's minds.
It was actually her idea.
She was like,
so many people take ambien and they
sleep walk and they sleep drive and they
sleep,
eat and they sleep.
Fuck.
And they wake up and they
don't remember any of it.
Why does that happen?
Yeah.
And so I started doing some research.
I talked to this doctor named Stephen
[inaudible] and he prescribes a lot of
ambient,
but he also helps people get off of
Ambien and he's asleep doctor for script.
Bitchy
fucking tricky web gets
you off and he goes,
listen,
as long as you don't take it every day.
One that try again.
All the really crazy thing about Ambien,
it's supposed to be a
short term prescription.
Oh,
you're not supposed to take
ambien for longer than 10 days.
So a lot of people who have
chronic sleep problems,
they'll take it once a week,
something.
Well,
it's just amazing that we live in this
culture of addiction where it's so many
people are addicted to cigarettes and
coffee and things that don't fuck up your
everyday life as far as
your functioning too much.
But we're completely triggered into them
and addicted to them that we would be.
So we would,
we would so readily prescribed things and
just hope the person we're prescribing
them to has good self control.
Yeah.
Because if they don't,
they're going to be physically addictive.
If I give you a bottle
of oxycontin and I say,
hey man,
here's 30 pills.
Don't take more than one of them in a day.
And you go,
okay.
And then you just take 10 of them and
then you're fucking guns Ville and then
you start shaking in your
coffin and you need them.
What did I do?
Did I just trust a dummy?
Exactly.
Well,
and you could,
you could have them take them water
day and they'll still get addicted.
Oxycontin is extremely addictive.
Benzodiazepines,
there's a reason that they say,
do not quit taking this medication without
speaking to your doctor because you
can't,
you'll go into withdrawal.
I mean,
if you're on Valium,
Xanax,
you can have grand mal seizures.
When you try to get off of it,
you have back spasms.
I mean it's,
you can die.
You know,
you,
you're,
the pain is so bad that we have to give
you this and we have to take the risk.
Yeah.
We have to take the risk.
Is that,
that seems
what it is for everybody.
It's,
it's all about the risk.
You know the people who take Ambien,
the reason they continue to take it is
because they're weighing the risk against
the benefits.
They know there's a risk that they're
going to fucking walk out into traffic.
They know.
I know.
They know that you know,
but their lives are so destroyed by
not sleeping that it does help them.
You know?
It actually bothers me because I did
this piece and all these people are like,
Oh yeah what pharmaceutical
company paid you to?
Or like you know or this
is so anti big pharma.
Everybody thinks that you have
an agenda when you write science,
but really I'm just trying to look at the
available evidence and write about it.
A lot of the available evidence when
I looked into ambien showed that it's
risky.
It's really risky
a drug,
but it does help people.
You know there's always two sides,
two sides of that coin.
That's the real issue isn't there?
It looks like for some people if you have
good self control you can use it as a
tool.
But the issue is that there's a lot of
people who do not have good self control.
What should we do?
Should we make things
completely unavailable?
And that comes to the Chagrin of
personal freedom when it comes to yeah.
Or should we make it completely available?
When I,
when I'm talking about ecstasy and acid
and GHB and all these things that I've
done,
I had so much control back when
I was doing drugs cause I'm,
I'm a pretty kind of paranoid person
and I don't drink because I never liked
feeling drunk.
I don't like feeling out of control.
You're paranoid,
but you do an ecstasy
and Ghb at the same time.
Exactly.
That was my dumbest move there and
I never did GHB again after that.
And I've only done ecstasy.
Maybe like I say,
only be like 10 times I've done acid,
maybe like five times.
But I would definitely,
when I look back at my drug history,
I experimented with drugs.
I would never became addicted
to any drug I ever did.
Yeah.
I've never fucked with anything
that's completely addictive.
I've never tried heroin and
we're trying to earn her.
Yeah.
The coat are the ones that are,
I just saw too many people
just lose everything.
Exactly.
And,
and still to this day more,
I've seen more people over the last
decade or so fall apart because the pills
than anything.
Yeah.
And I played with pills for a little
bit because I like to downers.
I liked drugs that I could have
fun on and then go to sleep on.
And the problem with things
like Xanax for example,
which I really liked back in the day,
is that for somebody who actually
does have a little bit of anxiety,
you take a dose of Xanax that's maybe
a little higher than you're supposed to
and you feel so good,
but you also feel so sober,
like you're fucked up in that you feel
more sober than you've ever felt in your
life.
And so you're talkative,
you're warm,
you're emotional,
but then you can go to sleep
at night because it's a downer.
I mean,
it's very easy to sleep on these drugs.
You wake up refreshed,
you don't feel like you were
doing drugs the night before,
you don't fucking remember
anything that happened.
I mean it's the same reason that
people probably abused ambien.
You feel good when you're on it.
So Xanax makes you feel sober.
I it made me feel sober.
Definitely.
So do you normally feel high?
No,
I think it's that people who are anxious
maybe have a little bit of an edge all
the time,
you know,
maybe a little stress.
And I also struggle a lot with depression.
So I actually do medicate.
I take an antidepressant every day.
I take a very low dose of Selectsa
and I know that I need it.
I know what I'm like when I'm on it.
I know what I'm like when I'm off of it.
I know that my brain chemistry is such
that a mild selective Serotonin reuptake
inhibitor helps me prevent
having major depressive episodes.
It helps me be functional.
And so now I am taking something that's
a daily maintenance kind of thing.
But back in the day,
I think that a lot of my experiments or
drugs were attempts to self medicate.
And when I would take
something like Xanax or Valium,
I felt sober.
Did you try?
Have you tried anything like five HTP or
have you tried any natural thing weighs
or,
yeah,
I mean,
and I think that for some people it's
a difference between talking about just
kind of your mood when you're
having a tough day and,
and treating clinical depression.
Yeah,
exactly.
Something that you feel runs
in your family's genetic.
Yes,
and I've dealt with it
since I was a child,
you know,
so actually it was only last year that I
started taking meds for the first time.
My whole life I've been in therapy and
I've tried to work really hard to not
have to take medication.
And sometimes I think it takes somebody
kind of hitting a bottom or going to a
place.
It's the same thing with people who
actually abused drugs and finally need to
get off of him.
They go to a place where they go,
I don't ever fucking
want to go there again.
And,
and that tells them,
okay,
I need to go into Rehab.
For me,
my antidepressants were
kind of my rehab from,
from my fucking brain.
You know,
my brain,
I know that I have clinical depression
and I know that it's a biological
illness.
You know,
mental illness has a foundational,
um,
route in your biology.
And so I've done the intervention
with talk therapy my entire life.
I continue to do it.
It wasn't enough for me,
you know,
but I tried it for many,
many years and I think that I just
convinced myself that I would be okay.
But after enough bad behavior and after
heard and kind of myself and enough
people in my life,
I finally decided this is something
that's important for me to do.
And now I really advocate for kind of
trying to erase the stigma with mental
illness,
trying to be as open.
It's not easy,
but trying to be as
open about it as I can.
So many people struggle with it and it's
one of those things almost like obesity
that we see in this country where
there's a fair amount of people,
for example,
who eat like shit and they're fat.
And then there's some people who are
morbidly clinically obese that have
something wrong with them.
You know,
like,
like nobody gets to be 600 pounds without
some sort of like mental illness or
without some sort of,
um,
by biochemical problem.
And I think for,
for um,
mental illness it's
the same kind of thing.
There are people who,
who can kind of work through it with a
lot of talk therapy and there are people
who have such a difficulty,
such a kind of biochemical difficulty
where they need medical intervention.
And I would love to see it if we could
start changing public perception about
mental illness to look at it.
Just like,
you know,
somebody has diabetes,
they have to fucking take
insulin and nobody goes,
oh,
you're just not thinking
positively enough.
If you just think more positively
yourselves can take in sugar.
Well it's always ignorant when anybody
tries to explain to you what's going on
with your consciousness or your body.
It's crazy.
And it's,
one is things that people do because
they don't like to see excuses in
themselves,
try to squash it.
They do.
And other people.
And what I say,
I actually did a piece a long time ago
about depression where I talk about it.
I was like,
I have studied this from a
neuroscientific perspective,
but I also know what I'm talking
about because I suffer from it myself.
And this is what I've done,
and I urge anybody who needs
help to get help or whatever.
But I talk about the
biochemistry and I talk about,
you know,
some of the kind of biological
causes of depression.
But one of the things that
I say in the video is like,
I'm so sick of people who will come
into comment boards and be like,
Oh,
you know,
just fucking buck up or whatever.
I'm like,
you know what?
I fucking want to be depressed.
Trust me if I can just
will myself out of this.
I would,
because whatever kind of pain it causes
you to watch somebody who's depressed,
bitch,
and Moan or cry.
If you,
if you've known somebody in your life
who suffers from depression and most
people do,
and if you've been there for them through
a depressive episode and it hurts you
to see how much pain they're in,
the pain that they're in is
worse than however much it hurts.
You.
Trust me,
they don't want to be going through it.
It's the same argument I say for people
who are fucking pro life when they're
like,
yeah,
fucking abortion.
I'm like,
you think anybody wants to
have a fucking abortion?
No,
nobody's out there going,
I want to get knocked up so that
I can kill the fetus inside of me.
Of course not.
They want the option if there's
a worst case scenario situation.
So you feel like,
um,
this is a universal situation
that all people that,
uh,
have,
that suffer from clinical depression,
that it's just some sort of an inbounds
and the chemicals that your brain,
your body,
I wouldn't say it's adjust.
I think that that the nature
nurture argument has to
come into play because this
is the,
this is the problem with neuroplasticity.
It's a problem.
And the perk.
If you have,
um,
uh,
let's say lower than normal levels of
serotonin or dopamine or norepinephrine or
whatever the combination is that
causes your specific depression,
if you have lower than
normal levels of that,
it's,
it's going to cause a lot of,
or it's going to contribute to
a lot of depressive thoughts.
Say that you have a lot of environmental
things that happened in your life.
You had a difficult childhood or you
experience trauma or whatever the case may
be combined with this,
the patterns in your brain,
the actual networks in your brain are
going to be reinforced in these depressive
ways.
So you immediately have a thought,
for example,
and you might go dark on that thought.
You might look at something as a glass
half empty kind of way instead of a glass
half full way.
And then what you're doing
is you're reinforcing these.
So talk therapy can actually help you
form new neural networks to come out of
it.
But sometimes that's not enough for some
people because there's still a strong
biochemical basis.
So they may need both.
But I definitely think that drugs are
never the answer without some form of
therapy.
You've got to work through
your day to day issues too.
You've got to have some sort of cognitive
behavioral intervention so that you
can learn how to cope with
the difficulties of life
because everybody has a lot
of difficulties in life and
people who have mental illness,
it's just that much harder
to get through the day.
It's that much harder to have
a relationship with your job.
What's the debate and the one,
the,
in the,
in the buck up department,
the debate is,
I mean,
I don't think it's a legitimate debate.
Not,
it's not.
It's trolling,
but,
well,
it seems like though that before you try
any sort of chemical intervention into
your consciousness,
you should definitely try
to get your health in order.
I think you should.
And I think that it also depends on,
on where you are in the spectrum.
Obviously somebody who is severely
schizophrenia who is having,
um,
a schizophrenia episode
who is out on the streets.
You know,
you see some of these homeless people
who are out on the streets and they're
talking to themselves.
That person needs how tall that person
needs medical intervention quickly.
Sometimes the medical intervention has
to come first so that all of the other
stuff can take place
because they're that ill.
Other times,
if we're talking about generalized,
if we're talking about
certain levels of depression,
it may be the case that
getting your diet in order,
talking through some of
your relationship issues,
your work issues and all
those things can exacerbate.
Then you'll actually
kind of be able to tell,
you know,
a lot of things are going well in my life.
I'm feeling really good,
but I still just have these days where
I start fucking crying for no reason and
I,
and I'm thinking about
ending it all and it's like,
well,
where's that coming from?
You know what I mean?
That might be something that we need to
talk about and try and have intervention
with.
But,
but somebody who is bipolar for example,
they're not going to be able to work
on getting healthy because there are so
mentally ill,
they're brain is so ill that it's going
to induce certain behaviors that are
counter to their health.
So being able to get on,
um,
on the lithium for example,
to kind of tamp some of the,
um,
manic behaviors,
like having unprotected
sex or going out and do,
you know,
binge drinking or whatever.
Yeah.
That pitch
she's talking about,
you know,
really what,
where did this come from?
I want to hear a backstory now.
Okay.
I just hang out at a comedy club.
It's getting late at comedy clubs,
just being a silly,
um,
but yeah,
I mean those people,
they may need medical interview.
Yeah.
When you,
when you talked about doing Xanax and
having that feeling that you were sober,
yeah.
Wouldn't you think that would be like
the ideal state of consciousness?
Have you ever tried to reengineer that
and find what the right mixture is to get
hit that ideal state of
consciousness all the time?
Just so paranoid now about
altering my consciousness through,
um,
through drugs that it's like I,
I'm finally at a place in
my life where I'm pretty,
pretty stable and I'd really,
I,
I know that I take,
um,
I take this Alexa every day and I are the
subtle a pram and I like the dose that
I'm on for example.
And I know that I'm in a room full of
men and probably most of the people that
are
listening right now or just one man here,
but so dudes
ears while I say this,
but I talked to my shrink sometimes
about the fact that like one time a month
for example,
I get a lot more emotional and she says
you can up your dose during that week.
I personally don't want to
up my dose during that week.
I don't like the way that I feel,
but I also don't want to just
medicate that out of myself.
I'm on the right dose right now that I
can still cry if something sad happens,
I still cry.
I'm not,
I'm not a Zombie.
I'm not numb to my emotions.
I found the right level so that I don't
always just cry for no reason and a or
so that I don't have like
a major depressive episode
that I feel like I'm never
going to get out of because that I think,
I can't speak for anybody else,
but for myself,
the way that my depressive episodes
worked or they happen was just like if
you've ever taken acid or you've been on
a drug at a certain point you're like,
this is never going to stop.
And it kind of sucks.
Like you kind of have this,
this fear like is this ever going to
go away or is this what I'm like now?
And that's how it would feel to me
when I'd go into a depressive episode.
It's like I'm so sad and I'm,
I'm crying,
I'm so low and I don't think I'm
ever going to come out of it.
And that's when I think for some people,
you know bad things like suicidal
thoughts or ideations to play.
When those guys run,
we run like the wind.
Yeah.
All right.
Typically you're crying for no reason.
And Girls,
Oh man,
we cry for no,
are you that?
That's good.
That's a better crying for no reason.
It's a hard one for no reason.
It's a hard one.
So I'm going to give you a word of advice.
All you guys who are listening,
no matter what she says,
if she starts crying for no
reason and she can't figure out,
and she and you go,
but do you want this?
You know,
get her.
What do you want this?
No.
Now what you need to do is you just
need to put your arms around her.
Really just put your eye.
Even if she tries to push you away,
just put your arms around their,
push you away.
Don't you advocating rape?
No,
no,
no.
Don't try to have sex with her.
Don't try to kiss her.
Don't.
There's such a difference between sexual
intimacy and emotional kind of almost
paternal intimacy.
Now you're just talking crazy.
You just put your arms around her
advice of your life right now girls.
Exactly like that knife had to
do that exact same and it works,
right?
It works.
You'll freak out,
but you just have,
everybody wants to be hugged and then,
and then she will calm down because she,
what she needs is to feel like you don't
think she's crazy and no matter what,
you still love her and
she'll get through it.
You are supporting crazy behavior.
Tell that bitch to get
her shit together and no,
no,
no.
Go to the bar and drink with your friends.
Listen to Joe.
Whatever you do,
I want you to get in your car.
I want you to put sweet home Alabama.
Crank that shit and just drive,
man.
Just get away.
This is not,
you guys want to stay single problem.
Listen,
there are certain tasks that
you do not want to take in life.
This is a guy who was making a
fucking monument to crazy horse.
He's,
he didn't completed his children
and trying to complete again.
You know why he tried to get too crazy?
Don't get too crazy.
This girl matters to you.
If she is the girl,
if you want to marry her,
if she's your life,
I want to do that.
If she's all crazy because
you love her anyway.
What if you just met her
and she's already all crazy?
They just do take on that task.
Sorry,
the all girls,
it's part of being the girl
is being a little crazy.
You're so raw,
are a little bit aggressive.
Oh,
not Brian,
not me.
Brian's not even remotely aggressive.
He might be your ideal man.
You've never been aggressive
in your whole life.
No,
no.
He is absolutely not the girls
ever being aggressive athlete.
He's not aggressive with guy's.
He's not aggressive.
Speak in generalities,
but rare bird.
I've never met anyone like him.
It's not uncommon for guys to be
somewhat aggressive and that comes on
different.
I don't even know what
you're talking about.
And it's not uncommon for
girls to be emotional.
I don't want to say crazy.
Look,
I eat so much I Denomie and
almond milk milkshakes with that.
Okay.
Yeah.
So you've got all of those Fido,
and by the way,
it's all GMO,
is that everything needs is GMO.
He's growing.
Yeah.
He's growling.
Fucking huge area.
Yeah.
It's there isn't that,
that is some what true that
if you eat too much soy,
your body and smoked too much weed.
No,
no,
that's not,
the real issue is that,
is that soy has a lot of,
it has high levels of Fido estrogens,
but there's absolutely reason to believe
that eating plant estrogens are
going to affect your own human.
It's a completely different model.
Vegetarian,
you're not,
it's not going to affect,
yeah.
That's like,
that's like saying this.
Like if a girl swallowed a bunch of come,
she would become more manly
because there's so much.
First of all,
you don't know anything.
They get stronger.
They just think better.
If there's a tribe in New Guinea,
not just one tribe,
but many that forced the boys at a very
young age to a ingest their sperm there.
Uh,
they,
and it's not just like one of them.
It's really fucking crazy.
There's like many,
many islands where they practice this,
where they take these boys away from
their mother at a very early age and they
live in these bachelor houses.
They live with men and the men
give them sperm to make them grow
and they think it helps.
They believe that's
the only one in Africa.
There are many,
many,
many areas in Africa where they still
have bushmeat where they'll still kind of
murder chimpanzees,
gorillas,
and they'll drink their blood because
they think that it gives them life force.
I think that it makes them stronger.
You know,
there's a lot of lore connected to that.
It's not true.
The same way that drinking sperm
would not make you pray that,
sir,
well,
these guys are the baddest
motherfucker on earth.
You should go there.
They're flying through
the air and climate.
All right.
Just so everybody knows,
Joe Rogan is advocating drinking your own.
That's not even advocating your own.
Your how scientific or you watch a
documentary on this boy's doing this.
It's,
it's look,
it's fucking disgusting
then that's going on right now.
And I was having this
conversation with a buddy.
We were talking about Greg
Fitzsimmons last night.
We were talking about
circumcision and how crazy.
It is crazy.
A child prettier child just died
recently because it's horrible.
Don't get it at home.
So we did it at home.
That big kid bled to death,
but that my sister's kids,
both of them went to high tech,
new hospitals and both of
their got shit got dis.
Like they fucked up the first time.
Say that go back months later,
put them to sleep and Redo it.
Put a baby to sleep to baby Jesus Christ.
But the idea,
but that's all it is at this
point in his tradition you'd get,
have you been with a guy that's had that
that cock before and does it creep you
out of three guys?
She's smart dude.
What?
Like 200 hey whoa,
that's big numbers.
Like three like most girls are like I saw
one was very progressive liberal girl.
What does that mean?
You Fuck African Guy
Straight to the motherland.
A lot of more progressive
and liberal thinkers.
Maybe people who have more liberal
parents are probably people who are less
likely to have to circumcised.
I've heard to date
you because you're so smart.
Oh,
I mean,
like,
do you know like most of the
relationships are you in smart guys?
So that's usually not an issue.
So you're out did fight.
But by the way,
just so you know,
I mean,
is anybody here in [inaudible]
you're all circumcised?
Yeah.
That's what we call them in.
And you're all circumcised monkeys,
guys who are uncircumcised,
by the way,
in case if you don't know,
it looks the exact same.
What?
It's hard.
Yeah.
We've seen porn.
It looks the same.
We know why.
Why does it freak anybody out of
the extra skin freaks people out?
Because whatever the sleeping bag waiting,
it's nonsense.
The sleeping bag.
Queenie.
Yeah.
It's one of the dumbest things
that human beings still do.
And uh,
and do under the guise really at
the lowest levels of it when the,
the Orthodox Jews do it.
Yeah.
And the rabbi has to suck the
baby's penis to stop the blog.
I don't want to talk about,
yeah,
you don't want to talk about it.
That makes me really
uncomfortable raising.
I know religion,
fucking fucking religion.
Yeah,
indeed.
How much shit do you take?
Like if you do something like this,
how much should you take on Twitter?
They're like from people that,
uh,
are Bible bangers.
Oh,
you know,
I don't have that many
Bible beater followers.
So I think they kind of know
because they're only going to troll
you and pretend they're bible beater
follows.
Because I,
you know,
I,
I'm an atheist and I say it a lot,
you know,
so hopefully that doesn't it,
it kind of does,
but I feel like I need,
I did,
I did an episode of,
um,
of this Internet show called the point,
which is,
I'm a young Turk spinoff
showed it's like an hour log,
just talk,
you know,
three people in a panel and a host.
And I hosted an episode that was all
about atheism and I made sure that
everybody on the panel was,
was an atheist.
And a lot of people are like,
ah,
it's so one sided.
And I was like,
no,
no.
This isn't a fucking debate as
to whether or not God exists.
That's not the point of this show.
The point of the show is to show
you what it means to be an atheist.
Where do we get our morals?
What kinds of people are we?
We've got to start getting rid
of the stigma because honestly,
atheists take more shit than
a lot of minority groups,
and it's one of the biggest
minority groups out there.
But if you look across the board in,
um,
in,
in positions of political power,
it's a fucking death wish.
If you tell,
if you tell your constituency
that you don't believe in God,
you're not going to get up.
Yeah.
It's amazing the idea that doing things
for just because they're the right thing
to do and it's great for the community.
Like that's never considered like the
people have to have some sort of a belief
in some sort of a,
yeah.
That they can't possibly
get their morals elsewhere.
Yeah.
It's impossible unless there's a deity.
It's so funny when people are like,
yeah,
but thou shalt not kill.
And I'm like,
really?
If there were never any Christianity,
if there's never any bible or I should
say Judaism cause it's in the first 10
books,
if the,
if that never existed we just would all
be like fucking killing each other and
nobody would ever stop and go,
yeah I'm probably,
we shouldn't kill each other.
So like it's insane.
Well
it's just so weird like as were saying
before that like there are positive
aspects to the idea of living your life
and I want to say a pious manner but a
or a spiritual matter cause that's really
tainted to moral a moral manner and
strive to be as moral as possible.
Loving golden rule.
I feel like the golden
rule is so kind of,
it's it,
it applies to everybody.
Do unto others as you would
have them do unto you.
And it's possible that if
everybody followed that most
of the disputes or people
have could be worked out.
If you really treat people as if they
are your brothers and sisters and you are
all in this together.
If we could,
but we could.
Got To figure out how to get everybody
on that same road because if that,
I mean if two people can get along in
a group of people can get along that we
can all get along.
We just have to figure out how to treat
everybody like they're in your group.
We love the Ingroup
outgroup status situation.
I mean everything comes down to that.
Everything comes down to in
group out group psychology,
whether it's religion,
whether it's politics,
it all comes down to us versus them and
it feels like so many people need of
them in order to define an us well,
they need that with Mac versus PC.
They needed with sandbox we do too.
I'm sure [inaudible] and t hello iPhone.
People get mad if you have
it and they have Verizon.
They'll talk shit about it.
I don't get any fucking service.
Even you can't even Google
search while you're on the phone.
What do you care about attached to me
switching providers and it goes back to,
or you know,
tribes of monkey people
trying to stay alive.
I,
you know,
being as close together as possible.
And that outside,
those are in Beta.
And it's funny because if you look at
two of our closest genetic relatives,
chimpanzees and Bonobos,
they're very similar.
Actually.
The banaba used to be
called the pygmy chimpanzee,
but we know that there
are two separate species.
The banaba only live in a certain part
of the Congo and they resolve all of
their differences.
There's sex,
they're like the most amicable species.
They just,
they're constantly fucking,
they're always sharing.
They're just these really
positive sex crazed primates.
Whereas chimpanzees can be
very violent and they have,
I mean,
they can also be kind,
but they have a strong idea of Ingroup
outgroup status and the string,
they still fuck,
of course,
but they fucked for a procreation.
I mean,
it's a very different,
they probably fucked for
pleasure from time to time too,
but it's very different.
Benobos when they,
when they're observed,
there's always having
sex with old related,
not related.
While they're eating dinner,
whether it be on their back,
they figured a way to stay out of the zoo.
Fuck like crazy.
So many people to the zoo.
The zoo doesn't want that
Novos.
Fuck.
They should.
They get so many more visitors.
Doesn't let animals do what they
actually do in the real world,
like supplying good cells to be a shit,
but it'd be really expensive.
Why would be so expensive?
Breed your own gazelles.
Why not?
That's true.
I mean if you get them,
have an animal and lock them in an area,
the least you could do
is give them some fun.
I mean,
give him the,
the genetic thrills that are put
in place that reward systems.
I feel like there's a
push with some new zoos.
Hopefully you're starting to see zoos
combining with universities where we're
seeing kind of animal behavior is
really being a big part of the,
of the design of the zoo and worrying
more about an animal's wellbeing.
Not just whether it stays alive,
but it's like,
yeah,
hell yeah.
I think that that's really right
in Denver at the zoo and we were walking
past this one exhibit and there was
this one monkey that was by himself
and he was wailing and agony,
just wailing.
And you could tell he was going nuts.
He's in this cage.
People were spinning around staring down.
There's nothing to do,
but swing from this rope to
that rope is a very small area.
And he was just SCO Riemann and it was
like a tortured souls like listening to
someone go insane.
Poor monkey.
That's fucked up.
You know?
How much is it worth to
watch that guy in real life?
Wouldn't it be better to like have them
in the jungle and make a DVD of it and
put it up?
But this,
this monkey might have
been born in captivity.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
It might not be able to go back
into wild cause it would just die.
But it's like when you go by
someone's yard and they have a dog,
a big dog,
and a tiny little yard,
the dog's going fucking crazy.
Like that's not cool.
You're torturing this animal.
You're fucking with his life.
And if that's what you're
doing when you're doing a zoo,
like shouldn't they have
like a minimal size,
at least with the intelligent animals?
I think they,
yeah.
And I think that newsrooms
are starting to do that.
The La Zoo,
it has a really good elephant
enclosure because elephants are up,
they're like elephants with,
um,
with apes we're much more concerned,
right?
Because of the cause of the
cognitive functions of these animals.
So a lot of zoos don't even keep elephants
because they're not comfortable with
it or if they're keeping apes,
you know,
that they,
at least,
I hope to see more as he
was trying because there is
kind of an argument for and
against zoos.
You know,
a lot of animal rights activists,
which I would never call myself
an animal rights activist,
but I call myself an animal.
Um,
I'm an advocate for animal
welfare because I am,
I'm for using animals
in laboratory research,
but I think that their welfare needs,
needs to be cared for,
um,
for like monkeys or rabbits.
Um,
and then we'll reframe it.
You know,
I,
I've been,
I've been experiencing
shifting views with primates.
I think that the laws have to be
much more strict with primates.
I would prefer to see prime.
It's only used for noninvasive
research instead of invasive research.
And I just hope that the places that
are doing primary research really treat
these animals with a lot of care.
Um,
they don't always,
which is dangerous,
but we all get that.
Did you see that?
Did you see the prequel?
I liked the prequel.
Yeah.
I thought it was really good.
Or what about that fucking 28 days later
when they gave him that rage and the
tools,
they give him the rage.
And that's true.
But that didn't like
happen in real life though.
That happened in the movie.
No.
But what did happen in real life?
It's just a scary when you
think about that do exist.
Oh fuck yeah.
Nutty.
How many we've created two.
That's what's really scary.
How many people have created these
biological weapons that if they got out,
wipe out giant cities.
Whoops.
We just want to see if we can make it.
That's true.
I mean that's true.
And we continue to,
to do this kind of research.
And what does this research mostly,
um,
uh,
funded by defense.
I mean,
this is national defense.
Exactly.
That's so true.
Banabos we'll have sex in every
combination except and son.
That's the only combination that
makes Benobos more moral than people.
That's true.
Because someone out there with some dude,
it's fucking,
yeah,
that's true.
And it's like somehow
they know or they've,
they've,
whether it's instinctual or they've kind
of learned some sort of disgust signal
through that because they,
if they bred mother and son,
they would end up with a lot of fucked
up genetic problems so they can,
they can fuck any others.
But,
but mother and son camp,
it's fascinating.
They must have just produced too
many bad kids and then realized that.
So there's,
there's gotta be a connection here.
Yeah.
But how would they know
who impregnated them?
If everyone
fucking,
everybody I don't know.
And they fuck face to face,
which is really crazy to watch.
Yeah.
It's really,
I mean,
it's kind of cool to see them.
They have sex like humans do.
And most species don't.
Most all species have sex from behind
because you got to look out for predators.
They're up in the trees.
Well also a lot of animal sex.
I would venture to guess it's
kind of rapey have a little race.
Yeah.
Little rapey cause you
paid any attention to uh,
the,
uh,
giant champ.
But they found the Congo,
the Bondo ape.
No.
Yeah,
they found this,
uh,
this guy named Carl Amon.
He's a Swiss wildlife
photographer and he started,
uh,
studying them in [inaudible] 96.
They have some camera trap photos and
then they started sending expeditions and
they found it's a
completely different strain.
If you look,
look Google image,
you see how big they are.
They're fucking dead wall.
The bondo,
a Bondo,
bondo mystery.
National Geographic has
some great articles on it.
I,
Nat Geo.
Yeah.
Love it.
There.
The,
it's a complete different subspecies of
chimpanzee would they have a crest on
their head,
like gorillas and they're enormous
and they nest on the ground.
They don't sleep up in the trees because
they're big and they don't give a fuck.
And the locals call them lion killers.
Oh,
they say they have two
different types of chimps.
Is there a giant chimps and this,
it's actually the same sort of creature
that was in Michael Crighton's book,
the Congo.
That's silly mood book
was apparently very good,
but the reason is a great author.
I don't,
I mean there was a lot of really good
science and I mean he gets very science
fictiony but like come on,
we even got the color of them
because they have a gray color,
especially the,
when they get older,
sort of like how silver
back's turned gray.
Yeah.
These chimps turn gray too and they
thought it could be some sort of a hybrid
between chimps and gorillas.
They're not completely sure that it's not.
This is interesting.
Most likely.
Most likely they think that it's just a
subspecies that only exists in this one
area called belly.
Well,
yeah,
I mean it happens like,
like the Banabos.
They're only across a certain river in
the Congo and they just stayed there and
evolved and they don't exist.
Video of one of them eating a leopard.
Oh,
that's amazing.
Yeah.
I don't know if it killed a leopard,
but they know it ate it.
Yeah,
they,
they're fucking huge.
These are like,
you know,
if you think about a regular champ being
150 200 pounds and having the strength
of whatever it is,
a 500 pound man,
how,
how big are these things?
The three,
400 pounds,
500 pounds.
They're there like at least a hundred
pounds bigger than a regular champ.
And they had a shred.
Some of them that are six feet
tall and they standing up,
they have camera trap photos of them
that like they say that's a six foot tall
chimp.
Yeah,
a six foot tall champ.
That's so a lot
and put that can exist.
Well I don't,
I'm,
I'm just saying that they've been
looking for it for a really long time,
but who's been looking?
Do you ever watch finding that's true?
Not that they don't know
what the fuck they're doing,
but they don't know what
the fuck they're doing.
Yeah.
I think there's somebody who knows what
they're doing has looked survivor man,
that's strong.
It's bad ass.
It's like a really fat.
Had him on the podcast,
he's going to go
live in the forest and try to find big
foot cause he hadn't experienced in
Alaska.
He had some bipedal thing
making AYP noise is really loud,
50 feet from his tent in
the middle of nowhere.
He said,
take a fucking picture.
Tried.
He tried to get out his camera,
but the thing ran away.
He was in his tent and he heard it walking
around outside in the middle of the
night and then he heard
said it was really loud and it was only
like 50 feet from his 10 he said it was
the freakiest fucking thing he's
ever experienced in his life.
He knew it wasn't a moose,
it was walking on two feet for sure.
He knew it wasn't a bear,
it wasn't making bear noises.
He said an ape.
And with that,
ladies and gentlemen,
this has been a three hour
podcast went by in 10 minutes.
You're a fascinating person.
Thank you very much for coming on and
if you ever want to come on again,
if you ever need anything to promote,
please let us know.
With Garden.
Yeah.
If you want to learn about
the number seven olive garden,
by the way,
love is in the Aa,
the town I grew up.
That's cool.
Powerful Kara,
Santa Maria on Twitter.
Ladies and gentlemen,
that's c a r a not Kara,
like that white trash bitch that
you went out with in high school,
but all the car carriers
with the care Mattamy.
Now listen,
I'm so sorry that I sacrificed
our friendship just for
a cheap joke in the first
place.
Hilarious.
I really have no issue
with carrots with a keg.
God bless you.
How about that?
Um,
thank you very much to everybody
that sponsored this podcast.
There's too numerous to mention.
They are too numerous to mention,
but I'll try on at.com ting.
Um,
and uh,
the game nursing games and
what does it bleed slinger.
God Damn it,
mother fucker.
Can I just say that somebody has a friend,
Jill friend of the show has put together
a desk squad calendar that has all the
everybody's dates,
your dates,
Christ,
your dates ever classes,
dates,
honey,
honeys mine.
And if you go to desk squad.tv,
it's desk squad calendar at the top.
And then we also have
some dates in San Diego.
12,
12.
Uh,
I'm going to be there with a
couple people and in a Improv,
the 20th,
and uh,
I'm going to be in Seattle this weekend,
but it's sold out.
You dirty bitches,
sorry.
You snooze,
you lose blade.
Slingers the name of the game and uh,
it's two 99 on the iPhone app store and
it's pretty fucking sweet and they're
cool.
So I go support them and go by there.
What's to 99 folks?
It ain't shit.
It's a lot of work.
These people put into it.
Have some respect,
have some respect for Cara sent to
Maria and you could check out her page,
which is called talk nerdy to do.
You get it.
You fucks.
She what she's saying.
Talk Nerdy to yeah,
they can find it on post science.
Huffpo science.
Um,
uh,
talk dash nerdy dash two dash me.
What do you know about RSS feeds?
She don't know shit about RSS feeds.
I can teach you.
I can learn.
Yeah.
Um,
thanks to everybody out.
Do we,
do we include everybody?
Yeah.
Ting,
ting,
uh,
on it.
Uh,
we'll be back tomorrow with the beautiful
and talented Ari Shaffir are our
brother,
RSV fear.
First Time in the new studio.
And,
um,
and that's it.
Oh,
and these,
there's only a few tickets left for the
end of the world show with the honey,
honey.
Doug,
Stan Hope,
Joe Diaz and me.
1221,
2012 out of Walter in,
in l a Holla at your boy.
Look,
we love the fuck out of you guys.
We'll see you tomorrow.
Bye.
Thanks.
Ooh.